foreign
[Music]
okay
bro what's going on talk to me
[Music]
baby boy
give me a second
what about that what about now how the
levels now it's a little better now I'm
doing y'all need to turn me up still
lowish
that's crazy
Gerald Mack what's going on thank you
Nintendo I appreciate it appreciate it
no doubt thank you I'll put a mic checks
[__] you what's going on see y'all
what's going on no doubt no doubt yeah
I'm gonna mess with a little bit more
but uh yeah we got a good show we got a
good show popping off pyramid some good
topics
fresh off that 300 that 301.
everybody up in their Buddha what's
going on man good morning
let's go check out Super Chat got my IOP
valari pillow Friday and use it for
trials with solo Flawless there we go
the valori did it the Volari did it you
went solo florist for the first time on
his first I've seen he was comfortable
you had that velocity your elbows going
there
[Music]
and you know the Final Fantasy
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
using these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got it
don't stop
I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled put on the bo dog thing very
loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I ain't
heard a boy and you ain't gotta say it
I'm embarrassed for you I always been a
nerd never been a loser making Voltron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell an Uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and had to be swearing that real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be using these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapper and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
with regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social lower
my CD but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
foreign
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all the
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment
[Music]
foreign
day
[Music]
radio radio
yeah
my checks and all that my checks get
some bad checks from the Lord see what's
going on what's going on might check
from the little mic check check you know
what I'm saying testing testing testing
Can you guys hear me
can you hear me
like he like he's he's in like a very
sanitized room
well it's it's a different lens I have a
different oh you have a different lens
kid can I get a mic check sir yeah yeah
what's up what's up what's going on
what's going on all right I think we are
low no no I think you good I think
you're good I just wanted to make sure
everything's almost good I got to get
that um green screen off of my combat
talk oh okay you gotta get your green
screen on yeah I gotta find out how to
turn it off because we turned it on you
know one time and we never turned it off
so when you look at it you're gonna be
seeing my face all in the bathroom
that's easy I can show you all right
here you hear you and we we are live and
welcome to the I lost podcast LLC and
also live on lordsofgaming.net episode
number 301.
shout out to another glorious Sunday
we're back at school 400 400. you know
what I'm saying back at the round table
of the Lord's date and today we've got
Dead Island 2. Xbox confirms Hi-Fi Rush
success
PlayStation acquires firework Studios
and soft reminds me we have to talk
about Nintendo EDS Nintendo
and Joseph stated to Netflix and discuss
so we gonna get right into it so let's
introduce the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original Lords here at the round
table my co-host with the cobos my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the Hop of the young wolf my
man Lord addict of the attic show how we
doing sir
I'm doing okay how are you guys doing
popping into the church
what is with this popping this this is
my domain okay I don't tell you how to
do things in call domain okay I'm doing
things in the Attic domain the way that
me the mayor of
attitude
anymore we we bought some Sovereign
lands around us and I was the attic land
okay get a new lens don't know how to
act continue
it's good yeah but it's been a good show
man good uh good good week I finished
that that Mandalorian thing oh man put
the old topics up okay I gotta fix it I
keep talking I'll fix the topics y'all
yeah I finished um I finished snowfall
snowfall that TV show snowfall that
that might be just as good if not better
than power I'm gonna be Rose really see
I gotta watch snowfall and I said you
know oh you haven't watched any of it I
I've been I've been getting flak 2 the
same thing yeah I said I got to call uh
called you know oh yeah that's um isn't
that Singleton in them like it's his
last series I believe so full yeah
that's what I heard but it is it's
really really really good and you know
definitely I I like slow Moses is
definitely better than power I don't
know because I feel like power had
better highs now I'm not saying snowfall
don't have good eyes it's got fantastic
eyes but when stuff goes out on power
I'm into like I'm in shock yeah I'm not
gonna say those moments didn't happen in
Starfall but I will say it didn't happen
as much but I do feel like snowfall is a
better consistent show than power is
[Music]
of power right I've seen all of them
I've seen uh the uh the one with Kanan
I've seen season two I haven't seen the
one with Tommy
this is letting y'all know attic is more
urban than yeah here in the streets
and he saw all the BMF he
[Music]
see the reason that like I'm like this
associated with that is because like at
least with the other one it had some
Realms of reality on what happened in
power like there were some like links
that went to power but like on that show
I don't feel that because I don't think
it has anything to do with power so like
I'm not as into the show it's still a
good show but I'm not as in as I was
like watching I I feel like Kanan was
one of the best things they've done yeah
okay it was the 50 that was his um the
come up okay okay that's what's up what
games you been playing sir
um oh I can actually officially say you
know NDA dude
see there's some weird thing going on
right now where
some people could post their reviews
last Tuesday and some people could post
their reviews last Thursday so I was
like you know what if I can't post my
stuff to the 20th I'm gonna hold my
stuff to IOP today so after the the show
today you know my my full-blown review
all right come out I hope you guys enjoy
yeah I'm not gonna go too much into it
because I do want obviously I'll talk a
little bit about you know Carl usually
ask me questions what comes to that oh I
got Cheese games
but I won't really go into like
the hardcore details
Urban attic yo I can't
it's funny that you talk about that
addict because like did you see the
email today
no then we we were blessed through the
code for Dead Islands
how great how great that's awesome
amazing
amazing Post Release codes
so that's been in sir yeah it's it's
been pretty good uh I will say that uh
it's been a pretty chaotic week
um had family and they was in for like
two weeks but they went back to Arizona
okay
yeah so it was uh what's funny is like
he he got like
all the the the NES and SNES stuff like
old school yeah so uh it's been a pretty
chaotic week man it's uh but I'm glad to
have my my living room back because they
were staying with us there's all cramped
everybody over the crib yeah because
yesterday I went in there and I watched
something I think I watched jigsaw
because uh it's been so long since I
watched it and I was sitting in there
and I was like I can't remember the last
time I was in my living room like this
no
doubt and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also that's ostradamus
the Lord of clarity and Lord patron of
the iron bank PC's Master races oh Lord
Sovereign how are we doing sir
well good there's no Tales From The
Master race this week all I did was
download Dead Island that's it
it's all the work the PC got this week
that uh operating uh functioning correct
this week I was actually trying to get
some breath of the Wild on and prepare
myself for tears of the kingdom and even
that did not happen it was just sitting
there even on my lunch hour at work it
was just not happening
yeah because I have considerably more
responsibility now than I did even just
a couple of weeks ago so yeah
moving on up right that means no time
but whatever you know it is what it is
but yeah what did I do so actually
yesterday oh obviously we played some
Minecraft Legends yes I could talk about
that and uh yeah yeah you had the Army
to yourself I had the Army to myself
the stream and that's because I'm a mind
down that's that's not Saul's fault
that's that's the developer's fault for
not making it more vividly clear that
yeah once one dude rocks out no one else
rocks that's all for the whole team yeah
so yeah it's it's not for me like I I
understand the appeal of Minecraft I
understand that it's it's a demographic
right but I'm not in that demographic in
any in any I didn't play Minecraft
dungeons I don't know you know if it's
something that would be appealing to
them right because it's more is does it
have any other buildings it's like no no
it's like um what's the um the joint
what elf is about to die
um
joint where it's a elf a knight a wizard
and like elf is about to die
I don't know
Gauntlet oh okay okay I got you okay
okay yeah okay so it's more like that
okay so yeah it just it just isn't for
me but I you know what was fun was
fortnite we played a little bit of
fortnite yeah that was actually fun and
just like you know King King and uh
attic been playing this forever so I'd
like to see them and be like oh we gotta
go this way and then we gotta take this
this launch up launch up like there's
some depth to this game yeah I'm like
why are we on this remote flying island
of like yo what they got it all yo all
right they're gonna come up here these
zip lines we're gonna pop them and I'm
black
all of it was worth watching that stream
yeah and I was thinking it was literally
me and King just dictating everything
that happened
at the end and I was on top because
usually how me and King play that game I
take elevation he takes crown floor like
almost every time we do anything I just
naturally go above ground with like oh
you know a DMR sniper rifle something
like that because I'm more of a
mid-range long-range uh combat anyway in
that case
I just saw all I just saw I'm I'm
shooting the people in the back trying
to force them closer to us
someone's coming up and I just reach
over shotgun shot him twice go back now
once y'all told me to snitch I was like
there he is there it is yeah as you can
see them yeah
I said there you go guys
yeah that was fun that was fun I may
play more of that stay tuned
I had civil Surfer with the Gap yeah
that is that is so dirty so dirty like
you have roach from The Witcher floating
down
oh you should you should they have
shinron from uh uh from Dragon Ball Z
the Big Green Dragon
that you could that you ride on like he
said
you don't like hold below them like you
right
but this is the thing you can only use
those like quote unquote mounts as
you're landing on the island right you
can't use them unless you have a park
like the only way you can re-jump is if
like you hit something that makes you
re-jump redeploy or you have a perk that
lets you redeploy anytime you want yeah
that's called the areolas oh okay I
gotta admit I've never downloaded
fortnite in any way shape before me if I
stay on the hard drive
well I'm gonna tell you you never know
okay
I also played the street fighter 6 demo
when it came out about that yeah it was
all of it only on Playstation
sometimes it just see it it's weird that
why would you pay for that I gotta get
this first like
yeah it is kind of smart because then
you convince people that don't know any
better that it's a PlayStation game
right and I I get it but the pay money
for that is just weird but I get it I
get it anyway
I didn't play any of the story stuff I
want to save that for when I actually
get the game okay so I didn't touch any
of that stuff I just did the verses
because I wanted to play it with a
controller that I felt more comfortable
with and not some some you know bootleg
third-party thing
and I gotta say it came
the game still feels heavier just
because of the characters they're bigger
right they have the kind of exaggerated
proportions but the speed of it the when
it comes to like countering stuff
getting your moves off I got to give it
to the PlayStation controller because
usually I'm not really you know for
those type of fighting games Tekken
definitely right but like a 2d type of
game not so much
um it was pretty good to control it felt
really really good to control get my
Fireballs off get my dragon punches off
not grabbing like a like a gravity stop
teasing me bro
when you are in danger you're gonna go
back to what you're comfortable with
yeah I should have been uh better at
getting out to the grabs no but that's
the thing I wasn't even trying to grab
you I was trying to pull off Dragon
punches and Reign zero and it just
wasn't happening grabs are coming out uh
but yeah no this it felt really good man
these characters how many they let you
pick on the demo it's just Luke and you
okay gotcha so that's it but you get a
chance to really get in there with their
moves and everything it was a quick
question was the announcers that we saw
at PAX East
there was one human announcer you could
turn it off or you could put on that
announcer thing right got you okay okay
so they only they only gave you one and
it was the same thing like it's cool
because it's like it's it it's doing it
to kind of move for move yeah it's done
a really good job with that yeah they
did a really really good job with that I
I wonder does it have though do they
have their own announcer though like
their classic Street Fighter now it's a
question I'm not sure I'm not sure so
but I like the fact that they understand
that shout casting yeah comes to these
games is is a a good thing right but
yeah at the same time
do you need shell casters now
um I mean the way they say I go the way
the AI is going yeah the game is telling
you uh what you're doing verbatim right
you don't right there yeah that's the
scary things that are happening it's
exciting in some ways it was scary but I
will say this I think Capcom with this
game they realized the corner that they
painted themselves into with five right
that they make from the back they were
like this is Esports like you I don't
care what game you are you cannot come
out and say I'm an esport right the
community has to tell you that you're
gonna be that yeah right if not it's
around okay what game you are and it
happened with Street Fighter early on
with it no story mode just the verses
they just like they they figured this
was just going to be you know for the
fgc from the very beginning didn't
really care and then at the same time
you make it a console exclusive without
those perks that you expect on console
and they really it was very Rocky for a
a large I would say the first year or
two really
um and this game just they they know
exactly what they have they're making it
accessible to the new player the guys
that love you know when you think about
street fighting really about fighting in
the street yeah and that story mode is
fighting in the street
yeah and so it seems like um doing a
Power Bomb on a refrigerator
dude you had I had dude I saw a dude in
the trailer last trailer he was jumping
from roof to roof on a favela like it
was like it was some crazy stuff so I'm
excited to play that and and to see how
they bring the old with the new
um let me see what else okay oh I would
you ever Miss yeah go ahead real quick
I'm just sorry to interrupt you I'm just
I just scrolled through Twitter and
first thing I see is chess Gordon tweets
is Dying Light two dropped an update to
its Gore system and the day after time
they were holding on to that one yeah so
yeah so you know you guys remember like
last year I read a a funny email from
from my friend Gabe Newell yes yes yes
okay so the subject matter
are you truly dead or alive
and this is from H.E Ronnie jumo oh this
is legit this is legit email we gotta
pay attention
says attention customer
this message is officially from the
United Nations
300 episodes
continue continue this is going to
notify you that your funds 2 million
United States dollars only has been
officially released but now our problem
here is that one Cynthia Edward came to
inform the PD shout out to the spellings
to the spelling it came to inform dust
that you are dead as a result of covert
19. oh they they notifying us of our
death okay got you as a result of 2019.
this is lit this is lit and before your
death you instructed her to make claim
of your funds U.S 2 million that was
long abandoned in your name with Chase
Bank oh what action do we need to take
because you know that's the next thing
this fund 2 million United States
dollars
is officially approved as scam victims
compensation
so the the board of scam victims
compensation is looking out for me
and my dad so how fortunate
this is really cheap yeah so so here is
the big question this is I definitely
language that the United Nations have
used
that's the big question
has been big problems to the board to
the board directors of Chase Bank not
knowing whom to transfer your funds to
oh they confused where the money gotta
go today they got confused yes yes
please just get back immediately if real
you are alive
what is going on I want to know what
they want us to do this is the call to
action
your date of birth yeah what what did
they want for your routing numbers
let me double check you're actually from
this bank
so let me go this this is the first term
right what's the first term what we got
to do first off did you authorize
Cynthia Edward to come for your claim
that's for I have to prove that that's
to prove that okay two are you truly
dead or alive
yes or no from the afterlife
so check this out though if no
you are hereby advising as a matter of
urgency to reconfirm the details of this
message within 24 hours oh my God hence
your funds shall be wired into her
account without any more DeLay So
if you cannot confirm that you're alive
in the event
fastly oh you were advised to reconfirm
the details of this message and get back
immediately with the information below
oh what's one of that that's the here's
the part it's the part his full name
full name we got to get direct telephone
number all right address yes your
personal identification to enable us to
confirm you are not dead
and current occupation and address wow
man they doing their due diligence it
likely is on your head this information
above must be provided for
reconfirmation to enable the Chase Bank
carry out your payment to you in case
you are alive
to respond back within 48 hours
48 hours 28. your funds will be remit
wired into her account oh we gotta stop
Cynthia from getting this back get this
money 2 billion U.S 2 million U.S lastly
do get back to me immediately do get
back to me
this will enable me to update my
official record of your death yo shout
out to the foreign commission Man United
Nations
I felt like I wrote that
and this is
all in capital letters what I require
from you if Only You Are
just me just mail me and speak to me in
quotations I am alive
we gotta stop that we gotta stop they
out of there the scam is going too crazy
man you heard about IOP 300 that is
something different now now we getting a
different level of scam that's crazy so
to end if not you are at your own risk
but besides Big Daddy besides you're at
your wrist buddy
Yours Faithfully h-e Ronnie jumo
yo sometimes because I have to go so
sometimes we'll get codes and stuff that
go into the junk mail and sometimes
nobody sees it so I'm like okay no I
gotta make sure that that's not going
into junk um yeah it'll be embarrassing
so I've got to really show Cynthia how
alive he is
so the last thing I would be remiss if I
did not wish baby bro Lord kaibatsu a
happy birthday today is today it's today
oh happy birthday
to the baby bro that's what's up
exactly my baby brother like this man is
a savant at game he he really takes care
of the podcast behind the scenes when it
comes to like uploading it and stuff
like that I know we gave him eight hours
of work the other day
and he don't be giving him no problems
in the comments he'd be checking y'all
if y'all get out of pocket yeah
disrespectful that man working hard man
especially when we go extra late salute
the kayak boxer happy birthday which at
this point it's almost weekly yes that
is almost weekly but yeah absolutely he
really he takes care of that for all of
us and uh yeah he's a beast at games and
uh what else was I gonna say yeah he
just doesn't you know he he's very quiet
doesn't he likes to be in the in the cut
in the background whatever so maybe
maybe we'll you know we're going to the
movies in a couple of weeks maybe we'll
hit a platform yeah
and of course we have our most technical
gaming Lord no we don't we have the
Incredible Hulk of this
aka the access gamer the prophet of Xbox
Swami King of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement
beloved Lord King fresh off that combat
talk how are we doing yo
160 live
y'all almost brought a tear to my eye
that's what's up
I do this to hang out with you know
people that's you know bored at night on
Saturday that don't get a chance to see
the fight or whatever and I'm just
trying to give them company
and give them a uh uh uh bird's eye view
into what I'm seeing trying to you know
articulate what I see on the screen
and I've been doing boxing forever
watching boxing talking about boxing uh
doing boxing
and to get to this space where people
want to hang out with me and we talk
boxing is something incredible is that
3.5
um
wow I I never expected it and I truly
take my hat off to everybody that was in
the chat you guys was in the chat you
always like tweeted out yo yo was
sharing it y'all did everything possible
and um I don't want to say Ryan Ryan
Garcia yeah
he really he put it all on the line
there's a lot of pressure on that boy's
head he was dealing with a lot of
emotional and mentals uh stress prior
earlier on or with a couple of other
fights that he pulled out from and he
was talking about mental health and
stuff
um
I think he got under the bright lights
and he buckled
you know uh he he was the taller younger
yeah that's the fighter right hand speed
tank was the more experienced experience
counts for a lot because tank sees the
bright lights and he doesn't fold right
I think understands that a setbacking
around doesn't mean that the fight is
over you know so I I think
um Ryan Garcia's management let him down
I think Oscar De La Hoya Bernard Hopkins
and his train has let him down because
he didn't fight the competition
necessary to get him ready for a tank
you know and I I said that
one they was going to stop the fight
with a TK on the 10th round that's what
I figured
um and he got knocked out in the seventh
round and not really knocked out but he
just didn't get up he knew what was
going to happen and he was afraid
I hate to use that word afraid with
boxes but he was afraid of the outcome
of if he gets splashed out yeah yeah so
well shout out the tank you did exactly
what you were supposed to do I told
everybody in the world timing beat speed
at all times your consummate
professional you guys shook hands and it
was a great fight
um yeah that was that was something else
the Kaka maker would do it every time
dude yeah I saw somebody shot I was like
oh brother in the delayed reaction just
like Oscar Bernard
and just like I see Oscar was Smarter
with that Oscar arrived on the floor in
pain and laid there yeah yeah I remember
that yes was sitting there looking at
the ref count to ten and hopped up at
10. yeah made it seem like he just
didn't want no more business he didn't
want those hands those hands was coming
gotcha yeah um what I'm playing yeah
what you playing okay Fortnight with the
team yeah yeah yeah and we got that
chicken dinner
my first time ever getting winners with
y'all that was fun um I was hoping we
get a chance to do that Minecraft ain't
my thing
he wasn't like in the pillow nothing
about it nothing about it appealed to me
nothing nothing like it goes to show we
could make we make anything fun just by
the bed yeah just us being foolish us
being foolish was hilarious but on his
own I'm not about that kid okay so
um I was happy that we got a chance to
play that
playing this game called Loop hero okay
yeah
talked about it okay attic champion this
game this game is probably the ugliest
game the next vampire survival
so imagine it's better than that it
looks like it's on uh
and you get this game that's supposed to
be on a floppy disk I'm playing it and
I'm so damn hooked I am so damn hooked
in this game
yeah I'm playing that
I can't say
it more just like vampire Survivor
it may look basic but once you start
peeling back those layers what I got the
necromance out I'm [__] uh uh
skeletons to fight and and watching the
minions it's it's
when you try it you'll love it that's it
it's the ugliest looking thing though
don't go in there yeah that thing is a
straight dos game like illustrating Ms
docs
okay walking around like you have an
Atari 2600.
yeah the only thing I think I would
prefer in that game over what they did
is you have no control over your
character
um I understand why they did it but I
would have preferred
to have turned that into a turn-based
game or you can make it into a Mindless
just manage like because that's pretty
much what it is it's a management game
like you manage your equipment you
manage the uh the tiles around you to
get more stuff to go into another run uh
you manage who you fight because you can
use Oblivion on stuff that you feel like
yeah I'm not I'm not about that smoke
for this one or today I got you uh but I
would have preferred if you know they
would add a second mode that's like look
if you don't if you want more control of
your actual character we're going to
give you this turn-based side of it too
okay no doubt shot that God's hit man he
wants to know what's the game again
no doubt and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the Shinobi more
Incognito spreading that relation around
the IOP not tell you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear shout out
to Ryan McCaffrey shout out to podcast a
lot having me pull up had a good time
over there those guys looks like Destin
came back talking about what was going
on shout out to defining do Mr Maddie
plays talking that uh Joseph stating in
that uh Netflix situation which we will
get into as well shout out to the last
word ebontist I got Travis talk about
all these bugs going on in Destiny it's
just a bit crazy you gotta talk about
that as far as games I have been playing
obviously Minecraft Legends with you
guys
um ghostwide Tokyo Still rocking and
rolling really like that game really
like that game like the relationship
between the kind of that Spirit entity
that's hosting your body and the main
character and what's going on you know
performance is still looking but I
really like what they're trying to do
and be getting a little hidden signal on
these little powers and all that so I'm
liking that and then uh what else make
sure oh make sure you guys check out um
Lords gaming.net this week some stuff
coming hopefully ended this week that's
really I'm really excited to talk about
really excited to show you guys can't be
one of them NDA dudes
right now but I'm really excited to see
you know once you guys to see what we
cooking up on that and um yeah no poll
last week because we did a seven hour
eight hour show and [__] forgot they
went to sleep
so uh yeah we're gonna get back on track
with that and don't know honey and all
that none of that today right no no
actually real quick I do want to say
though I never read YouTube chats
because you know sometimes you get in
there and somebody's gonna in there
trying to you know insult you or
whatever the case I don't I don't
generally read them but you know I
appreciate all the all the feedback yes
but last week I felt like let me see
what people are saying right after that
show
I I've never seen such an overwhelming
amount of just love shown in one space
in spaces that are generally can be
toxic right the conversation gets goes
left a lot almost 95 almost 9500 yeah it
was it was really something cool to see
so thank all of you guys for all the
love you guys showed in the chat it was
it's really something special even the
people that kind of like hated a little
bit but it was funny he was like you
guys are awful awesome too bad you you
hitched yourself to the Xbox
too bad you hit yourself to this sinking
[__]
too bad you have friends over there so
immediately people jump on oh but stop
plays most of your PC what do you do yes
boy have it and he's like clearly you
don't watch you don't know what's going
on you know it's like King is the one
that this that I was like oh this is my
heart I was like all right yeah yeah so
thank you guys I was that that really
that was that was really heartwarming to
see man because I've never seen a chat
with that much love in it and very
little virtual very very yeah it was
crazy it was super less super let's get
these super chats because they already
see people there I see Jay Barney and
then everybody acting up they've got to
get these super chats let me copy paste
that last one for me
back okay and I got a patreon question
after that okay cool we got necromances
they'll remember for one year ten dollar
Super Chat got my IOP valari pillow
Friday and use it for the trials in
Destiny 2. all right went solo Flawless
for the first time on my first attempt
coincidence that Volari did that there's
that Volari baby that's right yeah the
premium gaming Comfort he said they may
have to be banned like Cronus and then
unfair advantages
don't need to know what you're doing you
know just keep on man keep going to the
lighthouse
there we have Robert Kelly new member
shout out to Robert Kelly put the
question Robert Kelly thank you brother
two dollar Super Chat any of the Lords
played the pixel remasters
um I had them downloaded on my uh steam
deck God knows for how long yeah have
not played them yet did you pick it up
[Music]
[Applause]
I have to like uh Focus where the lenses
like the reason it zooms in like that is
to find out where it needs to focus
because if if I would have did it like
here it would have focused on the actual
wall yeah you need to focus
it's not on Xbox I don't I don't know
and it will they be no right no yes no
they're not um I mean I I might still
play here's the thing it's not that it's
on Xbox not the reason of playing it
it's the fact that I just got so much
stuff going on that I do want to
eventually stream all of them because
and I remember I was talking to solve
and so I was like play all of them I'm
like do you don't realize how many times
I've beat multiple of those games it
won't take long it won't I've seen him
play ff7 on the switch and he was just
flying through them
breezing through yeah I think he picked
it up on switch though
what did PlayStation do that you can't
give him the money they paid Square Enix
I'm not giving them more money for them
to pay Square Enix not to have games
come to Xbox
One
I I I'm damned if I do when it comes to
their first party because I actually
play games
um so I gotta deal with that but no like
that's other places
it's not and I could play at other
places
situation here though do you think
that's the situation here with it that
that was a block move that was I don't
know if this one was a block move
Enix is probably in talks it was Sony
about buying them because
huh so what you gonna do that if they
just then I won't take a stand because
they own them at that point
no it's not been in the knee it's just
being realistic if they own it like I
don't mind if you buy something and you
and you rip it off other platforms I
mind if you spend money not to go on
other platforms like because there's two
different practices one is you're
investing into that entire ecosystem the
other is you're just trying to make sure
other people don't play this game
you ain't feeling it
all right interesting interesting all
right no but I I haven't I have a strong
abandonment and what's funny huh no
you're a stronger man to be continue
no but it's just like and people say
well why would they block that why I I
don't know like why didn't why why'd
they block Final Fantasy 7 remake that
came out three years ago to come on the
platform like if if Sony can make the
the competition look weaker than they
are they're going to do it like I don't
understand that's like a a lost concept
for people why would they do this why
would they do that because it's Sony and
they had what's funny
is there's literally documents out there
proving that they do this stuff and
people still come out there and say why
would they do it at it I don't know go
that's Sony seems personal
money Sony is
personal if we gonna move on
I'm sorry I had to get him started
I wouldn't know there was something
behind this I just don't think it's
always so I just sometimes I think some
of these Japanese companies have an
apathy to Xbox before whatever the
reason I don't know what what if it's
just economics and they like the numbers
ain't what the numbers need to be and we
want to go over here where we can ensure
our great numbers
out no the reason I don't believe that
is because I've actually talked to
people and they say nine times out of
ten unless it's like a very Niche game
there's no realm where a Final Fantasy
game Port doesn't make money on Xbox
it's they're being they're it's being
chose not to do that you know how long I
was told theoretically uh a port for
Final Fantasy 7 remake with tape four
months and they said they could easily
pay for that in a couple weeks
like it's not that like people be
sitting here acting like it takes all
this time and resources I've talked to
multiple dads it does take time and
resources it's not as much people be
thinking the bulk of the pro the bulk of
the project goes to making the core
product and then when you start to talk
about the porting ends that takes a
significant less amount of money than
the porting itself especially now
because these machines are very similar
that is fair enough fair enough Attica
spoke a continues okay let's put the
crest in the chat Killian
then we got slow-mo backslap remember
for 34. hold on hold on real quick real
quick Jabari get on you with that
nonsense if it wasn't worth their time
ever why'd they put crisis Court explain
that to me
back to me right now in the chat if it
wasn't worth why did they put something
on the PSP on the platform I have to
give out of that part because Crisis
Core doesn't make any sense they're not
consistent that's the issue issue is it
because if nothing makes sense to put on
Xbox then why put anything dude you know
why Crisis Core is put on there because
PlayStation know that is low-key
promoting the own stuff that's only on
their platform what oh you know you
could play Christ school I love this
story this universe how do I play it you
got to play place
I will give you this the other
econsistency is octopath one why doesn't
Place usually have that and then
octopath two like it again my thing is
probably there's some bags going on but
I agree with the inconsistency if it
truly doesn't make sense make on Xbox
you don't put it on Xbox and all but
we'll see
[Laughter]
who's getting content now your destiny
bums
the division content for a year and two
games what's destiny future in three we
got a road map sir
wait what is this thing coming this
dude's been quiet for three years they
get like a little DLC popping off what's
going on they got mobile stuff
oh man I might pick it up on Ubisoft
plus and then done unsubscribe after I'm
done
absolutely slow won't finally getting to
talk after four years
we got final shape sir you ain't got
nothing to compete with that continue we
have a road map sir
that we have Nintendo Taco five dollar
Super Chat Crazy Cow [__] abuses power
to remove Nintendo from the show
I love how none of y'all responsible for
topics
no no he don't go to King he don't go to
attic he don't go to software
I'm the one that removes everything
then we got Robert Kelly uh and you
remember two dollars of check can't wait
for another eight hour epic fam not
today sir no did we not doing that we're
not doing that today oh nobody
big mad bro remember 33 months Lord
bronze salute to the realm and the Lords
thank you sir what's up brother
absolutely salute
we got Hollywood rules remember for 15
months Lord Silva happy Sunday Lords
fight night was spicy last night thank
you king I don't get to see all the
fights so your show is huge IOP the best
part period thank you said Cog is
Nintendo racist
I came up with Covenant with the switch
come on now stop it being a tree against
Mario
then we got Cypher pole 92 member for
one year five pound super chat for those
of you that don't tune into combat talk
you're missing out King's insights in
real time hit different yes thank you so
much thank you he knows what he's
talking about and got Sith Lord member
for six months five dollar Super Chat I
want people to send some love to
Randolph or 19. yes his dog Shakespeare
passed away this week I know the pain of
losing your best friend yes
I got very fortunate a few people
actually beat Rand in person and came
through the crib up yo Shakespeare is a
huge dog like it's a big uh rescue dog
um that um remember like the old what's
the cartoons yeah like he literally is
the epitome of that like when I first
saw that door I was like ran I don't
know if I could come through in the crib
if I ain't getting past that he's like
that Shakespeare is cool the most
lovable dog huge if you ever watch Xbox
two you would hear Shakespeare bought
because he was really big really loud so
condolences to his friend and everything
yeah that's a tough one I know how that
is man yeah that's that's tough that's
horrible mm-hmm
all right and then we have Jay Bari 20
Super Chat yo Cog no excuses so what if
the podcast is seven eight hours put up
the poll pause yes
[Laughter]
go go straight to sleep we get it right
we get it right
no doubt there we have Robert Kelly two
dollar Super Chat Square might as well
be Sony first party yeah I mean it's
that is the the natural next step right
it has to kind of feels like it's coming
okay and we have like I jumped a little
bit let me go back
God definitely got jumped hold on okay
here we go we got THX 1138 two dollars
for the chat bang Bang Yeah I'd have to
use a bang bang bang that's it okay yeah
that's it bang bang no doubt then we
have GST AKA getting stuff done five
dollars for chat congrats on the success
and discipline to earn it I got my
valari pillow no more sock no more cream
what you doing sir what you doing what
are you doing sir I'm pain-free whoa
whoa whoa what's what's the socks and
the cream about it sucks the cream about
there well you all know what you be
doing with these Volaris but you know
that's your own
listen we appreciate the support do as
you will do as you will you kind of put
that out there like that
then we have Michael Askew Junior five
dollar Super Chat Cog being messy on
Sunday getting addict at Super Saiyan
level two yeah
so what if they may set them off
there we have Lord Metroid two dollars
Super Chat I agree with my Nintendo
brother Cox stop it
all the Nintendo hate they're good they
go for me today
because he said he wasn't the biggest
fan of what he saw on so that's
something yeah you know you know if you
criticize anything from there
then we have a slobo backslap five
dollar Super Chat what is the final
shape your final DLC will be having
division Heartland and the upcoming
division three years before you're gonna
use Destiny PVP Max I'm back alive part
of me hopes that final shapes the last
thing sir um your active users or
division can you give me your stats
because I have I have the stats for for
even the worst DLC so to speak life for
blues they're all records away but you
know
they finally gave you a piece of crumb
because it's something that you've been
waiting
yeah
at this point I'm just like I just want
it to end at this point but that's not
what the numbers say but we're gonna
move on
it's still it doesn't take away the fact
it's still like you know how like people
people in the chat wouldn't get uh you
guys wouldn't get this but call uh
Kingwood it's like equivalent to like
what moderate did with the shot uh the
Allied Forces the destiny dropped two
giant meteors on them
it always goes back to the active users
yeah the facts
the amount of people playing the game
has no relevance yeah just because you
like it and you got your palm pause with
division no one else cares that's the
fact sir get out of here you division
guys
Division if that argument worked Xbox
would be lit lit right now exactly so
what you pulled up the facts
I will stay I will flame you out of here
you division guys y'all know not the
best of me I'm being nice
thank God that came up while I had to go
to the bathroom oh yeah yeah
THX 1138 two dollars for chat IOP the
high-end podcast no family Hardware oh
Lord
there we have Robert Kelly once again
two dollars Super Chat Cog anti-italian
Mamma Mia
he said [__] if the actor uses GTA's bad
okay yeah GTA online is fire is that uh
what you call MMO though I'm talking
about the MMO space
uh then we have Randy G five dollar
Super Chat what will Square say if Final
Fantasy 16 doesn't meet expectations
I doubt that'll happen I hope it does
though like I I have my own little
faults with Square Enix and Sony but I
still want the the Final Fantasy Brian
to be what it used to be like I'm still
gonna play their games it's just like
when it comes to this you know the Final
Fantasy 16. as as much as they have oh
you're going boycott
no yeah
exclusively this bike club is coming to
Xbox baby so you know if they're just
gonna take a stand but they oh my God
it's only on Playstation
they said that at the bottom it said
that it still come as a one year or
whatever it is six months okay I'm not
waiting a year what have I ever waited
here for anything everybody's Gonna Take
A Stand Together We must go fight no
I've said multiple times I've literally
made videos saying look you could
boycott if you want but I hate doing
that okay but you boycotted it looks too
remastered
I said I was gonna buy it on PC not not
places
that's fine I'll be a super messy with
you right now I'm probably gonna give
that 30 of money to steam than I would
to give that to place
you are on your square with this I
respect it I respect it good diesel
because let me see let me see hold on a
second
that's it we're caught up all right cool
now we got a weird one with the um
patreon not weird but just a lot of a
lot of information I should say shout
out to sack shop on the Lord's Day
patriarch question we spend with the
Lords we have all seen the death rattle
from redfall Recently with the news of
don't nobody want this Nouveau I mean is
that a software right the cheating
software being included with the PC
version of the game Lord solve you know
what this means if others don't we have
all the spelling a little bit have all
heard about these anti-cheat tag along
programs that can make the game
objectively worse to them several months
later remove it typically once a game is
no longer selling to only see the major
Improvement in performance with that
being said are we now ready to maybe say
that redfull is not a game Microsoft
really cares about they're acting like
that girl in the corner who needs that
bread for the fix but it's acting like
she been clean for 47 years we tired of
the games man we hungry and we want some
food love you guys and I have to say
this because King said it otherwise my
bleep might be in trouble dance Bucky
dance
I guess like the the Nouveau and then
does Microsoft
um really care about the red fault
situation well I mean again it's a brand
new game coming out you know it's
actually the first game out of uh
Bethesda right coming out that's that's
exclusive to uh to the console right to
the console so it's it's important
um but at the same time
as as the hardcore we see some of the
things that they're doing that we feel
like they're gimping themselves and it's
stepping on a rake unnecessarily
the 30 FPS thing is is Big to us it may
not be big in the grand scope of things
but to us it's important and I think it
does the game with disservice for it to
come out on consoles not 30 FPS when you
know it's going to be hitting 60 on PC
now
the idea of it hitting 60 on PC is
hindered by the fact that de Nuvo has
been known to absolutely destroy
performance on PC yes
and what we realized is that the purpose
of the nouveau
at the launch of a game is to ensure
that it isn't bootlegged correct right
it is a bootleg for a week later yeah
well yeah again because depending on the
game and depending on the implementation
the Nouveau might be broken within a
week right and then it doesn't really
matter but maybe depending on the game
like they say in a final fantasy 16
that's a game of that sort of uh those
sort of Epic Proportions let's say it
comes out on PC day one right
you want to make sure that as many
people are that plan to buy that game
are able to purchase it without some
sort of let out of left field way to
acquire the game without without paying
for it so if it's a couple of days if
it's a week I guess it's worth it to
them to implement that and and screw
everything else up but again it has been
known to absolutely
destroy performance uh at least early on
and you know the devs know this the
Publishers know this and they kind of
work they talk around it when oh the
Nouveau is causing this any other and
then you know a couple of weeks later oh
we've removed it or whatever because we
got the sales you know sales begin to
Plateau for whatever reason and and they
figure okay it's okay to just leave it
out there and then all those performance
issues are sort of rectified so if you
look at that in the grand scope of
things
and you're like okay so you're gimping
it on Console you're kind of gimping it
on PC as well
it's not like the Game Pass version
isn't gimped with the Nuvo as well right
so everywhere that you turn there is a
butt when it comes to this game
so you know yes can somebody infer hey
what are you doing to this brand new
game that's coming out the platform and
what why are you treating it this way I
I don't again they may have other
numbers that indicate that all the stuff
we care about isn't important in the
grand scheme of things we'll see to us
it's important and I do think they're
they're not giving the game the leg up
that it deserves I think so from a
hardcore perspective again I don't know
that it matters for a more casual player
or or generally that's the way I feel
about it but for me as a hardcore all
those things lined up together means
that it's gimped in a way that it I feel
they they know that it's going to begin
and for whatever reason it isn't
imperative on them to sort of not
release the game in that fashion got you
so addict do you feel that um according
to my man sex shop does Microsoft even
camp out red four with all this
situation with the PC the Nuvo
anti-cheat stuff and the 30 frames
console stuff
if you guys know how about PC like all
that stuff that stuff straight off that
platform yeah
part of me is like
I do think they care about it if they
did they wouldn't have delayed it
but I do think they've gotten to the
point where
we can't delay it again uh not even from
a perspective of the perception of the
game
but
where is it going to launch like I said
here in a couple weeks Zelda's gonna be
there a couple weeks after that Final
Fantasy 15 uh you know right now
Jedi will be out in a couple days like
they're already competing with Jedi and
you know out of all the stuff that is
coming out Jedi is probably the only one
you really wanted to compete with if you
had to I mean in June you have Final
Fantasy and you have Diablo and then uh
what
Starfield a month after that so it it's
just like look like
they have a whole lot of options to be
honest with you uh it's not an excuse I
personally feel like they should have
delayed it but I can understand from
like a schedule-wise where are you gonna
put it like this was literally one of
the only times that you could put
something like that are you gonna delay
it into the end of the year and then
compete with Call of Duty in them
and then not to mention Fours has
probably come out in like September
October you're going to compete with
that yeah tough spot way to put it and
then you're going to look at from the
from the bad PR that's like look it's
not 60 that's going to make
a small portion of people mad on Twitter
that actually knows what 60 frames is
compared to 30 but is the perception of
losing more trust that we push something
out
upsetting people and then you look at it
from this point you know the same people
in that chat that says Leo you know why
why is
why is redfall have 30 frames guess what
they would say too
They delayed it because they want you to
give the 30 frames why they meet that
June miss that June date
why this game's been delayed multiple
times what's going on for a year it's
like let's be real here I prefer the
delay I wouldn't even care about the pr
they're gonna get but they were going to
get smoke regardless regardless and to
me
it's like it was with the the uh the
the Halo
I the co-op I ain't played co-op in
forever but most the time it's online
co-op
um I didn't care when they cut that now
when they cut the the online co-op from
the game at launch that was different
but even though there's people like me
that would have played with you guys or
kid smooth am I to tell them to delay a
game
off of the minority of people that would
have played this game that would have
preferred it at 60 frames when I see
countless people always playing uh they
don't play the performance modes they're
constantly playing the Fidelity modes
like look I don't know that that's a
tough thing I still would have preferred
them to push it just so I could play it
at the best performance I'm sorry but at
the end of the day what am I doing I I
can't force them to do something no I
get it now we gotta see that's it's a
good question as far as um you know what
if if the the populace truly for the
console gaming space truly will not buy
something because of 60 Fair we will
we're going to learn a lot about that
King real quick about the uh redfall for
the patreon question do you think he
says do you think Microsoft even care
about it because of the launching at 30
and the adding the anti-cheat software
on PC well the anti-cheat software I
don't play on PC so I wouldn't know
about it
um so I don't really you know subscribe
to what they're doing with that from
what I'm hearing from you guys uh they
remove it a week later anyway so it is
what it is
um they wouldn't have sinned
all these influencers to small meet and
greets to promote this game to the
extent that they have if they didn't
care about the game
um they've been promoting this game very
well uh from the new metrics how we do
it now we it you know it's usually on
social media the game has been tweeted
out and you know um and it's up to their
development team to get the word out on
stuff that's changing and happening with
the game I think Microsoft cares about
the game
um I think a lot of you guys care about
the game more than Microsoft cares about
the game because you're scrutinizing
every move for the game let the game
come out and then talk about the game so
me personally I think Microsoft is
treating it just like any other IP uh
coming out the door and it's you know
it's literally their first marketed game
coming from Bethesda because you know
high five Rush was a stealth drop yeah
not fair enough yeah talking about too
much of you guys pretty much knocked it
as far as the uh PC version I agree with
you solved the um you know that software
anti-cheat software to me is always to
try to ensure
which already came out I think is
putting it in so people anticipate you
know new content or something like that
so that's how I see it I don't agree
that you know with the performance thing
I hate that aspect about it that's
that's kind of sucks as far as like does
Microsoft kid I think they care about
redfold they definitely do I just to me
I think this is if I'm gonna put a guess
I think this is them crap cracking the
whip so to speak in the sense that it's
got to come out and and regardless to
whether maybe the way Bethesda had
operated in the past pre-acquisition
versus Microsoft's end goals which is
they want to promote that you know that
they have the most powerful console and
even though that the third the 60 frames
won't be in time the fact that they put
out a message that says oh it's gonna
come you know what I'm saying at
whatever shows to be that they care
about that even though it's going to
upset people it's not available at large
I get it because I'm not happy it's not
their launch but to me it it it does
show that they care about they do it
other little things that show me that
they care about it so that's where I'm
at to me the key is going to be if the
game is good or not because if the game
is good like King said nobody's really
going to care anymore it is just it has
to review well though because it has a
lot of pressure coming into it with the
you know the always online the you know
the the what you call the IGN um
gameplay you know fiasco thing and now
the 30 frames so now it's already had
some it got negative momentum coming
it's up to them that this game needs to
be good if it's good gamers are forget
and everybody be popping and you see a
green Metacritic score and they can
throw their chests out yeah you know how
I go but if it's a one of them
60-something and them yellow joists it's
gonna get the smoke it's gonna get the
smoke and they're gonna be like yo you
should have delayed it or whatever
that's what I got we are going to move
on attic you are up man this game came
out it was one of them NBA boys for a
little bit on this Dead Island too it's
out in these streets let's talk about it
yeah so like I said uh people that
wasn't in the chat earlier our review
will be going live after the show be
premiering I would definitely send you
over there I I privated the video
because somehow some of you are getting
your hands on the videos
we're going to start implementing the
Nouveau yeah we got to break the frame
rate of the podcast down y'all in here
infiltrated I know I first noticed them
when we did the red fall content uh
before embargo we had them unlisted yeah
and you know we were trying to figure
out if we wanted to Premiere them maybe
not Premiere them do something different
and I've noticed the views were going up
and I'm like okay call Kai is a link
it's only about six of us yeah so so why
is there 50 views
and now I was like Yeah from now on it's
going on private and then you know right
before the podcast ends I'll I'll put it
as a scheduled tweet so it's just like
look
you know I don't know do you have
questions you want to ask me about this
guy yeah I just um you know obviously
the history about it did you play any
song because I know unfortunately not my
all my gaming time went to Minecraft
important thing and then the lady
stopped was like no no
you're done no you're done no I guess
the question obviously you know the game
has been in development for a long time
like nine years I think they showed this
thing one of them old e3s I went to I
was like like way back in the day when I
first saw it so we know about the
changes so I guess you know the first
thing off the bat is speaking the man
and stuff like how visceral is it you
know the open world aspect and there's
in general the fun level you know as you
have people go past your screen which is
awesome but
but just in general like how I heard
like it's really visceral and how is
that at the gameplay you know overall
it's probably one of the best looking
games and uh on the Xbox series X oh
yeah it's definitely one of the most
visually stunning looking games ever
yeah you know just Graphics it's like
the small features they do like when I
hit there's like
assassination uh animations where like
if you're using like melee weapons like
let's say brass knuckles or something
if you if you stun them and do the
correct prompts you literally punch a
hole through their head
it's some of the craziest Gore I've ever
seen like I noticed when like I I
knocked down a zombie I cut his leg off
so he couldn't chase me anymore and then
he's sitting there like he's crawling to
me and then I cut one of his arms off so
he couldn't crawl and then like when you
go behind him and you're hitting like
the back of his back like you see the
gashes that you're doing on them and
blood's coming off it and the material
that the shirt he had was what was was
being hit to and you could see the
material everywhere behind him and you
know what's funny is I was playing with
kid smooth and and kids move was uh he
was killing some of the zombies he's
like you know what he's like this he's
like they they do dead black people
better than other people do it like
um
yeah
so it's definitely a very visual looking
game yeah I did see something
um somebody had like some claws like
we're thinking they're like you could
get in this zombie like mouth and the
jaw come off and hanging from the side
like all type of brutality up here like
the visualness of it so that that is
crazy so they like in terms of we got to
get to the elephant in the room you know
what a lot of people consider one of the
top zombie games would be like a you
know could die in light and all that
comparison so like
you said visually nothing ain't touching
it but what about the sandbox and the
things that Dying Light sandbox or dying
lights better okay okay but
after you get over the fact that you
can't jump over every little nook and
cranny like that's in the game and you
start to like really put yourself in
Dead Island too and not Dying Light you
start to like real like okay you know uh
I will say the combat
and Dead Island is better than the
combat and Dying Light also because I
feel like okay yeah because I I felt in
control for the most part when I was
doing stuff you know but is is there
parkour elements no there's no
it's a rounded typical it's a very
grounded like it it's Dead Island one
but Dead Island two location okay uh but
they you know they increased all the
little things that you would expect for
them to increase like I remember uh if
they have no problem overwhelming you
with zombies like there's a lot of
incidences in this game where they're
like just run don't try to fight them
there's too many of them uh so they put
these things in here like you know
there's like these water cans that you
can put water everywhere and then you
have like the uh what we used to do is I
would put the water everywhere and
smooth would have like the electric
baton and he would just start hitting
the water lightning everyone and you see
the lightning reaching up and just
hitting the zombies and keeping them in
place like
he talked about you talked about the
combat you talked about
um the visual style but what about like
the crafting and the narrative that's
what that's I want to know like how you
feel about the story because narrative
is a very safe narrative like you you're
not gonna expect anything more really
that like look I don't think anyone play
zombie apocalypse game or watch a zombie
apocalypse move for the night let's be
row here it's it's always very
simplistic we are stuck in a town
There's zombies everywhere and we're
trying to survive I literally just told
you the beginning middle and end of this
game pretty much yeah but we're here for
the experience but they they do do a lot
of nice mechanics in the game that make
the gameplay change different that there
there is exploration like there's this
mission where they're like yo go go into
this place and then that leads you going
to in a hotel and you're like 24 is up
and there's fire everywhere and you have
to like go back and forth between the uh
between the elevator Shives and it's
just like little little things like that
and you know that's in Dying Light it's
like I would say you know the line
between this and Dying Light is very
thin the only difference between these
two games really is the parkour to a
degree gotcha um I do feel like some of
the the actual zombies in this is just
is is just you know part of my life is
bad [__] crazy like they got like
screamers like that that if what's funny
is like I I do that State of Decay like
joint yeah I picked um
the person that had the highest agility
and one of her abilities was is like
let's say a screamer is screaming you
can't get close to them because of that
the vortex that they put out I had an
ability where I would literally pretty
much just like jolt in front of them and
hit them and then
sooner or later I got that ability to
where when I hit them in electrocutes
them but it hurt me like they just got a
lot of the only thing I could really
criticize this game for is I don't like
the card system it was like how they did
the level up yeah
yeah I I like I like cards stuff but I
don't like this and it what it was
pretty much is is like they give you
cards throughout the game and it's their
version of your your your uh your RPG
tree where you have to put a card in a
certain section in the afterwards you
kind of get used to it but I'm like just
give me RPG trees I'd prefer that then
look at this car what's this car do
what's this car do uh you find them
randomly throughout the game too uh you
know it's but it's it's definitely got a
lot of depth into it you know there's a
lot of different things you can do I did
like how they kind of put the one thing
I've always liked about the the Dead uh
you know the zombie games is I love
dead risings
psychos okay okay and they kind of have
that a little bit here that's one of the
biggest thing I've always loved is how
they do the Dead Rising psychos like
where you you fight the I'll never
forget like in Dead Rising 2 where you
fight the uh the psycho in the bathroom
with the glass like they have a glass
and they're going between the Stalls and
grab you and stab you right like it's
stuff like that I really enjoy you know
and they have a little bit of that in
here addict like the most wildest I
can't don't even you love all of us he
is too giddy over there if you if you
look at the remake of that game too like
when the cycle is moving he's cutting
himself at the same time wow he's crazy
I mean they call them cycles first yeah
last question I got for you is reference
to the um the Cooperative asset is it is
it like drop it drop out drop it drop
out okay cool is there is there
tethering do you have to stay next to
you and kid had to kind of be or could
y'all go off um I if there was tethering
it was so large of a skeleton okay no
doubt no doubt but there is not only
dropping and drop out but you do keep
the progression nice that's big that's
big that's the first thing I tested I
was like kids move I'm popping out of
here I'm see if you kept your stuff no
doubt so we got your full review going
up live after the show you know what I'm
saying Premiere you so go stick around
for that this would be some good content
also Lord go to loads of gaming.net
because we got our review up there as
well my man magic Gene you know what I'm
saying had his thoughts on it anything
else uh King herself or Dead Island
before
this is not a game pass
that's all you care about
shout out to kids
oh okay that's what that is that's what
it is
you assessed of the situation so I'm
just I'm glad it's a good game you know
obviously this game has been developed
for like a decade and uh you know I was
very happy with the results yeah you
know obviously I'll get a little bit
more detail in the review but I was
definitely because I kind of felt like
there was no way this game wasn't going
to work you know what I'm saying and
playing it I was I was pleasantly wrong
and I'm and I'm happy with that yeah
especially just the characters like you
know the characters all have depth like
the characters you pick yeah and it's it
kind of reminds like a a final
destination moment where everyone like
the beginning of the game everyone's at
a plane and you see all these people
come together to get in this plane and
the plane goes down and then they make
you choose one of the people in the
plane is your main character oh okay
salute go check that out y'all wish you
could have had an interview at paxis I
know it would have been great you know
it would have been great to have more
information beforehand on this salute to
the team in fact he's got a chance to
double that jump but uh that's what I
got uh some you have some super chats
you have to read no I don't yes you do
yes you do
yeah Robert Kelly two dollar stupid chat
expect 30 FPS on Xbox outside of Forza
in Gears
if that's the case I'm on PC full-time
on the rail if that's the case I'm on
pc4 though I'm not playing redfall on PC
if if I give it on Console the only the
only way I wouldn't do it is if I didn't
get it if like the Xbox code didn't
carry over the PC but as of right now if
I'm able to I will be playing redfall on
on PC I'm not playing on Xbox and
I think we have Micah skew Jr remember
for two years five dollar Super Chat let
me find out IOP crew turning on to Among
Us with the content leagues
somebody did it somebody out here
leaking
let's play with each other's joysticks
five dollar Super Chat SOB don't worry I
would let you play with joysticks as
much as you want
thank you I appreciate that
thank you thank you so much
he just put up some lucky girlfriend so
you need another one wow
then we have Mike is cute Junior
remember for two years two dollars
it's a trap yeah I think that's that's
pretty well clear clearly I think the
only things I wouldn't play on PC and
you couldn't pay me enough is like
massive multiplayer games like I will
never jump back on PCO Destiny I will
never jump on on PC with any type of
like highly infrastructure multiplayer
because every single time I've jumped
over on that PC nonsense I you could I
on Among Us on Destiny there's been
cheating to the Max and what's funny is
I will play 10 games of Among Us and
five of them someone was cheating and
then someone says they start Every Game
Addict yeah about half of them though
open
platforms no wall Gardens here if people
watch football games and only half the
games that you watch someone's gonna
cheat I think people would have issues
with it
psycho addict the third evolution
yeah let me see anything else I think
we're good we're caught up slow-mo there
is cheating on consoles very very
reductively they they are cheating and
there's people that use modded
controllers Etc but people acting like
they the same they not
going in yeah you're going in so look
this is me uh yeah some uh we gotta talk
about Hi-Fi Rush a lot of talk in these
uh social media streets shout out to
Jeff Grubb looks like on the game where
there's kind of a sequence of events
where the uh his game master science
podcast he said that he had heard that
Hi-Fi Rush didn't make the money it
needed to make this is a game that was
previously described after its surprise
instant launch as one of the most
successful launches for Bethesda and
Xbox in recent years but he said based
on what he heard it straight up didn't
make the money it needed to make it got
good reviews and the buzz was good so
where do you put the blame on something
like that so it seems like I said that
went out
and then after that Aaron Greenberg
actually looks like he replied to to
that as well as um just going and make
uh talking about those comments um about
that grub had made in reference to high
fiber success so Greenie says Hi-Fi Rush
was a breakout hit for us and our
players in all key measurements and
expectations we couldn't be happier with
what the team at Tango Game Works
delivered with this surprise release so
then shout out to Grub he did respond
back to greedy responding to him and he
said I shouldn't have said needed on the
podcast I don't know what it needed to
do the conversation we were having was
about genuine generating revenue and the
game didn't hit that Target but no
matter what Hi-Fi Rush isn't a flop and
Tango's future is bright so this set off
a chain of events you know because
initially when first people heard Grub's
first thing that it didn't do well
people were like hey what's going on and
then obviously you know Greenberg kind
of responding which kind of rare he
doesn't really respond to a lot of
rumors and stuff like that Xbox in
general so I wanted to know what the
Realms you know feels about this Xbox is
confirming that a Hi-Fi Rush is a
success so let's start with you addict
how are we feeling about this
I felt like it was a fantastic game and
if it didn't succeed in any way shape or
form I would have very disappointed uh
you know I don't I do think that Jeff
grubb's sources was right to a degree
but I don't I think it's in a different
concept than people think I think Jeff
probably you know talked to someone that
talks to people in Microsoft not an Xbox
and you know maybe they were saying from
like an output content they don't know
what's going on Xbox or that degree and
they're probably looking at it from like
a financial aspect or something like
that because they probably just saw the
the numbers the strict numbers that they
brought back and they're not putting
game pass because that's not their
philosophy who knows where they work at
uh so I do think there is some truth in
that but here's the thing it's like I
said in the the video I made you know go
out and look no further than them
expanding uh game uh Tango Tango game
you don't expand some of the flops if
they if they flawed they would either be
staying exactly where they are or being
downsized and being set to a support
Studio they wouldn't they wouldn't be
yelling it's like equivalent of me
failing bombing something and we're
still gonna pay you yeah we're gonna pay
you but you know what you know what king
come help him
why is King gonna help me when I fell
look at imagine what thought process I
would have a key he's I don't want to
help that loser yeah
yeah it's just look like they
they gave them more money like why would
Microsoft give a company more money that
a that that it hit the nail uh the the
numbers that they internally wanted and
B just didn't deliver what they thought
they were going to deliver you don't you
don't extend people's budgeting for no
reason like like it's just like a quote
it just it it's crazy that people would
think that and you know Jeff Krav he
made a video uh it's during the podcast
I didn't watch it either but you know
clearly he he felt away because he
this is how
this is how Jeff Grubbs influences
people you know they go in on Jeff grub
you know is he right about 100 Things No
but Jeff grabs right all about a lot of
stuff you guys just like to hyper focus
on the stuff he's wrong about and not
focus on the stuff he's right about Jeff
Grubb made
statements on a podcast and he ended up
being the sole reason why Hi-Fi Rush was
training all day yesterday bro it was
lit it was super late you even see John
Johannes jumping in take a look he was
messy I love it yeah
he's taking advantage of uh horrible
situation no doubt no doubt Lord
Sovereign
that's the other thing that's going
around here like yo greedy capping he
just he's just talking to me talking so
here you have it this much Greenie just
doesn't talk when he calves like he he
responded by itself means something
continue so I'm sorry no listen he
it's Successful by every metric that
they care about really like you guys got
to remember
their method of selling you games now
their primary method of set quote
unquote selling you games is Game Pass
but I want to look at the MPS that's
nice that's real nice that's real nice
that's secondary but the MP3 says even
even tertiary
it really it is not it is not the metric
that they care about the most and they
understand and realize that on Steam I
think it has somewhere close to 500 000
sales that's great it's a 40 game it's a
40 game that in total did better than
forespoken did a seventy dollar game but
it wasn't on MPD so it means a failure
it's a failure yeah uh this is one thing
when I when you talk about how you
change the way you change the way things
are perceived right because you changed
the metrics of it right and the fact of
the matter is that game passes change
that metric and for Microsoft the metric
is whether you like them not it's
engagement it's how many people are
playing the game because it kind of
gives you an idea of how where Game Pass
is proliferating right yeah
that I'm going to remember this
so for me it's just like yeah you know
the metrics that they care about is is
Game Pass how many people in Game Pass
are playing this game right they got
their bag up front they gave them the
bag up from whatever the case may be
and anything that they make piecemeal
right A La Carte is fantastic on the
side and for it to sell for it to be
available in Game Pass a small game that
a game no matter how good it is it's a
cartoony game it's a rhythm-based game
it is not for everybody I don't care
what price it is it's not something
that's going to appeal to everybody so
for it to sell 500 000 copies on Steam
and we don't I don't really know the
numbers on epic game store it was on all
of these Platforms in addition to being
on on on Game Pass PC being on Game Pass
console that's what they mostly care
about everything else is a plus
piecemeal sales is a plus whatever
piecemeal says that they actually got on
Console right because you still have
players on console that I'm assuming
would just rather purchase the game than
get it from Game Pass you have that as
well like to me the metric is Game Pass
their method of sale is game pass this
is what they want you to engage with
everything else is is sideshow to them
and if it does amazing numbers in that
realm they're gonna tell you if it does
amazing numbers just just to kind of
Stick it to you anyway yeah but it's not
what they really care about so again
the way the way grub sort of formulated
that was kind of it it it doesn't make
sense that that would be a conversation
that happens it doesn't make sense that
a conversation would have between
whatever Phil Spencer and Sasha nadell
about Hi-Fi Russia and do themselves
numbers but we have you know 30 million
uh uh Game Pass subscribers and most of
those people played it at least for a
little bit right you can't want once
you've changed the metric internally you
have to understand that that other
you're actively and this is you know I
know people give Colin Moriarty a lot of
crap for saying this but it is true Game
Pass as the primary method of of
proliferating the Xbox ecosystem now
if training people not to want to buy
games out of card because you expressly
first party games like forget about that
you're gonna get it in Game Pass so it's
like it doesn't make any sense that that
would be a conversation that happens
like yo the numbers the numbers aren't
on hi-fi Russ is not what it is unless
of course the game goes into Game Pass
and you have one percent engagement and
you have oh you know we have 30 million
Game Pass subscribers and 10 000 people
played the game then I could see a
conversation happening like okay this is
this is not successful gotcha um but
beyond that like uh it's like apples and
oranges now it really isn't and the fact
that it sold half a million on Steam
says something fair enough not fair
enough Lord King we've seen this came by
your line high five Rush success being
questioned greeny jumping outside we
don't really see that what do you feel
about all this King
I find it funny that uh when Hi-Fi Rush
dropped everybody was oh it's the
greatest in sliced bread PlayStation
dudes is like oh it's not coming to the
PlayStation uh it should be on
PlayStation
and um
you take one individual that has a
source you I'm pretty sure that you can
get a couple of sources in Microsoft
that can either say that it was success
or it wasn't you know if you get a
financial dude that only goes by sales
numbers maybe it was not a success to
him right so if you use that source and
you won't out your source of course not
so there you go right that's that's the
problem right there so you want out your
source to say Ted told me
told you that the sales numbers wasn't
good and you said I'ma run with that
likes and clicks and Views is used What
hap what people got to do right I mean
if you run something that is uh tailored
around news you got to be the first with
the news be it right or wrong and then
you can hide behind uh my source set my
sources said my resources there's the
sources in the building that told me
that high five Rush by every Quantum
Quantum native what say it again
quantifiable quantifiable metric metric
is a huge success
the game had no marketing dropped that's
a good part so stealth drop so no you
didn't know what was coming it same day
you can go download it the steam is a
indication of how successful the game is
because they have purchases I'm sorry
excuse said Byron is about to pay Ted a
visit
I'm sorry that was wild funny continued
it's just it's just the fact that
y'all look for any little reason to try
to uh any success that Microsoft does
have are you implying there's a certain
group of people who do not like success
stories from Xbox no I'm not fine I'm
saying that's what's happening I just
feel that
people think that the negative news
towards Microsoft would
help them in the short run with certain
things
um it's easy to hide behind a source bro
very easy out Ted in accounting
nobody is out and they saw us get come
on because you can sit there and say
um that this you know my source said
that it's this is not this it didn't do
what it's supposed to do but then you
got green come out and green owns it and
Greenie says man shut up it did did what
I'm supposed to do over here is a
success and by showing you is a success
we're going to give them the ability to
hire more people
check it out
Tom heard it and Tom didn't say anything
[Music]
um
you know because it didn't make any
sense
if it walks like a duck and quacks like
a duck it's a duck don't try to make it
a beer don't don't
chase the views in the like stuff I
don't I don't want to get into that
whole aspect with uh individual because
it seems like everybody's coming down on
this individual for saying something
that his Source said yeah for him
that's real right well everybody else
it's not real right so your Source makes
it real to you we don't believe your
Source because what we see in real life
it's it's doing its thing right so I I
don't I don't care I saw it on Tick Tock
I saw it on Instagram I saw it on
Twitter I saw it on YouTube it was
everybody was streaming it playing it
and in Zeitgeist with it so you can't
say that game was a flop and he said
it's not a flop he didn't say because it
didn't sell to what Microsoft
expectations was that's all but do you
think this is the thing right when you
say Microsoft expectations right you go
back to the singular person right that's
the thing I wonder that again and I know
this is information that journalists try
to get at right like the dirt underneath
how many people at Microsoft at Xbox
aren't on board with the Game Pass thing
right right how many interns how many
internally don't really believe in the
whole game pass thing and feel like all
the card sales are what it is that's a
good point you know so and that's a real
thing I'm sure there's plenty of people
at Microsoft who just are not on the
services bag yeah let me interrupt you
because you want to fire us off it's
funny you said that because I hadn't
heard from uh you know
I heard from another tab in accounting
that you know um like for example when
we had um when obsidian's pentiment came
out now we had Joshua on in in around as
far as I finally do he literally said
like that was a pitch he strong-armed to
get out because for them to have them
make the game fashion projects it was
literally he knew this was his only shot
so to King in your point you you can't
tell me that there are not some people
that are like man if we would have had
something else in this place other than
that you know what I'm saying it could
have did way better whatever so I do
agree with you that there are some
people in the building that will look at
you know competitively to like a Forza
Horizon or Halo infinite and don't want
certain of those type of games to come
out because they're thinking about the
bigger bag or the bigger picture but
continue I did I did want to mention the
pentiment story I'm 100 certain if that
if if higher-ups had their weight right
even people above Phil Spencer whatever
the case may be they would have tried to
convince them to be like okay Game Pass
is going to be a small game and third
party
game thing first party games we sell out
a card
I'm sure of it I'm sure of it because
they're like the we need again if first
party games create the identity of a
console of an ecosystem if they are the
ones that convince people to go to that
to that space instead of another space
we have to show that these games are
whatever they're worth whatever the 60
70 right you can't have them in this in
in this uh you know uh
service and to me and to me that is a
conversation that has happened and at
the end of the day we got game pass with
everything first party in it and
wouldn't you know whatever for us the
consumer it's fantastic I just don't
think that like King said people that
that punch numbers and people who have
been in a space where the status quo of
of the measurement of success has been
different before the game pass
are like no this isn't success by the
metrics that we think matter right and
you know whether there's some internal
strife there right that we don't know
about I don't know right but um
it just is what it is and but I do think
again going back to everything you guys
have said to this point I think the fact
that it's a 40 game it's a game that
yeah that is not going to necessarily
appeal to everyone no matter what the
price point is it had no marketing and
it was such a positive Zeitgeist
remember when I I told you guys when I
saw it I was like this looks cool for me
but I I said that the internet's gonna
come for us because it's like here we go
Xbox had opportunity to still drop
something hot and they stuffed out this
cartoony thing and it turns out it's a
great game and objectively you can't say
too much battle body is a great game
right and that's thankfully That's What
mattered over any other narrative that
could have proliferated right
um but yeah it just I felt like either
way it's it's kind of a niche thing and
you know maybe you dropped the price to
20 bucks you know in a couple of months
or whatever and see how many you know
units that moves or if you some DLC or
something that kind of brings it back
into the conversation
um but yeah I just don't I the man
metrics are different and that is that
whether you believe it or not whether
you care about it or not whether you you
know you think it's a lot low to BS and
it's just just them changing the
conversation for it to sound good right
whatever the case may be that's what it
is
I hear you hey shout out to Thomas or
smaller King he said you're right King
he said it's why he never really reports
on comments I always need to see proof
Etc the money metric isn't what they are
chasing but some teds see that lack of
Revenue as concerning so he agrees with
you and again you know it's about the
metrics internally I'll jump in you know
in reference to this this was
interesting because I got to be honest
I can't remember a time where Microsoft
responded to a rumor
um
especially like a garage you know see
you in the Chantal Palace in salute I
can't remember a time where they direct
so quickly was the clap
and you know and shout out to Grub for
you know kind of walking it back a
little bit you know as far as the sauce
and stuff like that but um yeah to me
look marketing one-on-one
you don't respond to something
that as far as like rumors and stuff
like if it's bad like you you stay quiet
like for example rev 430
it's kind of quiet right you ain't see a
jump out response back really on that
as far as this to me that is like oh no
we I don't look at it as corporate speak
because it's not to your advantage it
because it will be disproven if if it
isn't a success so to me I'm with addict
on this it's like
they have to be happy internally with it
again we talked about the stealth drive
we talked about straight into into Game
Pass right the key to me is what attic
said though you do not expand Tango game
stupid game work if you think everything
going over there is not not great
and I got to be real child like the way
Tango moving
played you know finally got a chance to
play Ghost wire I really enjoy it you
know I'm saying Hi-Fi Rush was an
outstanding success you know obviously
my comedy's gone and he still got a lot
of talent there they talk about the
rumors of um what is it a jrpg addict
that we were hearing about a new IP like
to me this is the stuff I want to see
from Xbox like I the fact that they got
like a Japanese Studio by proxy of this
whole acquisition thing is really
exciting and I looked at the expansion
you know shout out to Hazard or he said
um if they got the Techno game work on
Studio almost 150 employees and then
they are opening additional 30 more jobs
right so they're looking for expansion
they're looking to take that means they
like what they're seeing what's going on
over there to me that's extremely
promising so yeah I got it I gotta admit
I think this is something that um
overall Microsoft is happy with and I'm
curious to see what Tango continues to
do in the future I'm very they put it
this way they are moving up the ranks
they're getting close to in that top 10
top five range if they continue on with
these type of games so yeah shoot a
salute to them that's really all I got I
just thought it was very interesting you
know we should do one day we should do
we should write all the studios yes and
do like uh we should do a tear like the
Sab yes with all Xbox games too because
I'm telling you right Tango is coming
man Tango is coming I'm letting y'all
know I like what they doing off rip
exactly you know I really do and then
with more money I love I have I'm
excited about what they could do if they
really go back to like pure survival
horror or stuff like that and just do
other things as well I think they're
just gonna be really diverse yeah I
think they're gonna be diverse too
because Shinji said before he left one
because you look at a guy like John
Johannes right that we had in the room
interview for Hi-Fi Rush young cat Hi-Fi
Rush is a complete departure from the
horror and stuff that we used to see in
front of them right you got that Danny's
talking about we want to be more than
just a horror Studio we want to have
diversity we're gonna obviously we got
ghost wire down here in the rumors of a
jrpg could you imagine like a jrpg on
Xbox debut and that's mind-blowing to me
right and then we still got the horror
bag which we do whatever we want to go
we got evil within three we could hit
you whenever we ready kind of energy
it's exciting it's exciting for for to
see what's going over there so salute to
them you know and we will see what else
goes on during the whole you know Saga
of Tango or even success anything I
think real quick I think it was
misconstrued in the chat by somebody
like when I said somebody above Field
Spencer maybe doesn't like the game you
know the services thing I mean Satya
Satya is definitely the services guy
right but this you know you can't tell
me if the guy that's in charge of of
Windows it maybe is right yeah it you
know Windows used to sell for how you
know however many hundreds of pop and
now you give it away for free do you
understand like yeah you know they used
to sell a version of office every single
year yep yeah and and again there's
something to be said for the services
aspect of it where you pay a
subscription fee but not a lot of people
do that because I can go I could I could
show you a site right now
no danubo there
so like I said it guaranteed that
there's people in high places at
Microsoft they would prefer to sell
things out of cart oh for sure
guaranteed that's a good point because
it's like the old office days where you
have to buy okay office this one came
about office that one came out now it's
like Office 365 subscription was 360.
what's up right give me 90 a year 100
years something like that and if that
works out and it's more financially
beneficial for Microsoft long term then
that's the metric they're gonna stick
with look this is all about the business
of making money period you don't come up
with a system like Game Pass look we get
it it benefits us right now you know
short term but we get it the consumer we
benefit on that side but let's be clear
Microsoft's in the business of making
money right there's no way they don't
construe this plan as far as engagement
and Game Pass subscribers unless they
feel long term that's the way they
commit the most money you know if you
get them to reoccurring payment or
whatever whatever that's what it is that
was up to them to feed the service to
continue to have games into the service
that are quality that makes people want
to subscribe to the service so if
they're in my opinion if they're happy
about it that means a they have some
Metric that won Yo during that stealth
drop look how many people subscribe the
game pass you see what I'm saying during
that stealth drop look how much
engagement was had and as a result that
we've we saw them on record say like oh
were they in then they try this and then
they try that and then you know what I'm
saying so they clearly have something
internally that they are happy with and
again it's going to be that's what I'll
say it's going to be harder for
sometimes us and sometimes the regular
casual fan to understand that for them
sales isn't the end-all be-all not that
it doesn't matter I'm never going to say
sales doesn't matter they will
definitely pop their chest off if Hi-Fi
Rush was on MPD or whatever they're
going to tell you if it's there but the
the the reality is they don't look for
it to be there because if it's not there
but they went Game Pass went from 30 to
50 50 million subscribers oh that's what
they care about that's what it is so at
the end we'll see we'll see that goes on
but that's all I got let's get these
super chats yeah okay so we got God's
hit man
laying them down for the Lord two
dollars to protect you guys care Fable
is 30 FPS yes yes yes I do
I'm playing it on PC
de masturbation she plays
then we have Robert Kelly Two Dollars of
a chat Jeff got info from a bad snitch
or Xbox is lying
I just said Jeff you know you know when
you uh editorialized he took something
and and kind of without realizing it put
his thoughts into it rather than just
giving the information I mean it could
be very listen I don't want this about
the grub grub is the whole no no very
well be that like King said someone he's
talking to feels that way about it it's
like yo you should have waited wait that
should have weighed way more money yeah
than what it was right and then you have
the other one again it's also also
addict we've talked about there's levels
to sources too right there's people
right he says that and it's like if the
it's a high level Source saying it that
maybe he feels Justified saying
Microsoft feels this way right
absolutely absolutely so I don't want to
disrespect because there's times where
you know again people who are really
close to the situation then there's the
high UPS we don't know what source it is
but I do want I just wanted to stress
that aspect of it because maybe there is
someone in the building like nah him
that should have did it
I just think it's it's just it's
interpreted different ways on different
sides that's just what it is and that's
you know you may think that's BS but
that's just the nature of it that's what
it is
then we have a zip Davis chat my oh my
that Volari pillow is so comfy
me
thank you congratulations enjoy enjoy
hargit to new member for one year two
dollar Super Chat finally got my Volari
thanks for the support and quotes thank
you that y'all like that I like that I
like it I like that put those up put
those up on the Twitter the socials
we got Mike Askew Junior member for two
years ten dollars will be super chat you
can respect grub but grub and other
content makers have to be willing to
change their Outlook or they will be
irrelevant moving forward it's the same
as the music industry come on man I'm
not coming at the club man you got the
Xbox fans don't like what Gruff says
yeah
it just seems like we're assuming that
he that grub himself feels that way yeah
grab just supporting what he reported
man yeah I guess I guess you know it was
just one of those things that he worded
it in such a way that he was going to
catch smoke for it like this well you
know I mean you know Xbox Beauty gonna
be like are we going yeah
what his news they don't like yeah
continue Robert Kelly uh five dollars
for chat Chad is little Timmy's dad he's
snitching out of sadness and stop people
being delayed and running at 30 FPS hey
we gotta see
then we have pixel bit G member for two
years five dollar Super Chat the person
who is the real champion of services
that Microsoft isn't Phil it's
supposedly Sati yes it is Satya there's
no way that we may not have Xbox if Phil
were not able to convince Satya a pivot
that included that sort of services
based thinking so yeah yeah salute
salute salute the field diamond
if I Rush sold more than four spoken on
Steam despite Game Pass really well yeah
I told you it's all about I it beat it
out it beat it out on stage I sold about
500 000 and that's the 70 game this is
similar that's interesting okay or
spoken Studio
I'm sorry yeah for a spoken students
they closed the doors because again the
metrics were different the expectation
was different Jim don't play that
yeah
it probably would have done great on
game passes
for locking yourself off for two years
Tango is expanding Xbox targets
engagement like I said it's very true
Bethesda slash Tango likely had sales
targets before being acquired
interesting yep and let's see what else
we have here then we have Nintendo taku
two dollars of a chat I think 10 angle
will become the second coming of clover
oh I like that yeah yeah dope then we
have Marvin ginyard two dollar Super
Chat doing my part to save the Nigerian
polar bear thank you I appreciate it
thank you all of it every time you hit
the like button man we save a couple
Nigerian polar bears what other animals
we saving okay what are we doing we hit
the like button y'all you know how those
polar caps are melting in Nigeria
it's even an African armadillo
hit the like button save an animal there
we have a spot to go 17 two pounds Super
Chat NDA dudes back at it again huh come
on bro
shout out to NDA dude salute they got a
list I can't let me just grow down
uh and we got gamer by choice five
dollars to pretend should we be beat uh
should we be on the lookout for
Microsoft exec leaving for personal
reasons exactly I feel Games should have
made more money Phil stop exact check
salute
I don't know when they come up with
these scenarios the scenario is
hilarious
chat oh yeah this is it I read that
already okay the second coming of clover
I like that mm-hmm uh that's it
recording all right solve you are up
little acquisition season right and then
Nintendo topic and the Nintendo topic
yeah so let's start with the with the
with the Sony acquisition right what's
going on so yes Sony has acquired
firewalk Studios you guys may remember
that they entered into a publishing
agreement with uh probably monsters
which is the actual the the dev that is
the the bigger umbrella under which
firewalk Studios was was uh operating
they entered into an agreement to make a
triple a PlayStation multiplayer game a
new IP in 2021 right and apparently it
seems like whatever Sony you know
whatever they've shown of whatever this
game is going to be has impressed Sony
enough that they've decided to sort of
buy firewalk Studios out from under
probably monsters and uh bring them
in-house and this is interesting because
it is the only really the second time
this has happened where um Sony has
purchased the company that they haven't
it hasn't made a game yet right they did
that with Jade Raymond's uh new studio
where they you know and entered into an
agreement for whatever game they were
working on uh an exclusive agreement and
then decided to just purchase them out
right right so it's interesting because
again we've been talking about this for
a while Sony has a lot of uh service
based games kind of in the works right
that we know they're trying to get into
that bag into that space cloud-based
stuff they they finally realizing that
they have to expand the wall Garden this
you know 70 dollar you know super
Prestige game is great but they do need
something that's going to make the money
kind of on a monthly basis right
so this is where they're going with this
now what's interesting about this and I
think we had already talked about it
that the two heads of firewalk studios
are former
we have Tony Sue yes and Ryan Ellis who
both worked as uh game directors on on
Destiny in addition to creative
directory oh yeah so they know what
they're doing in this space right so
it's kind of interesting to me that Sony
is really doing things that they have
not done in the past and I give a shout
out to to Colin first because Colin's
the one that always pointed this out
like yo they don't do this they gotta be
they gotta date you for a long long long
time before they decide to bring you in
after the holy College I got to start
showing because he knows I'm messing
with this so are you implying this is uh
not organic
not organic in the least oh okay of
course because there's no game that was
purchased before no nothing no game that
was made no no pre-existing uh
relationships they just outright bought
them and this is this is small exactly
it was an avocado to see you on Tuesday
but but oh oh so so basically love at
first sight 150 plus so they're
definitely that small not a little Ricky
dick not ranking dick one so to be clear
about the purity of organic growth here
in this situation
these dudes nice these dudes is nice but
continue
so this is the thing neither one of
these Studios has a game under their
belt they have a lot of talent that have
games under their belt and made games in
this space but they're still taking a
risk because you just never know right
Bungie's bungee and there's a certain
magic there right and no matter if
you've come from we've seen it with with
three four three and you know after
Bungie left it's like
you can't always the the secret sauce is
just what it is the secret sauce you
can't always guarantee success by having
some of the same people in that space
right right it's just one of those
things that it works it works and
doesn't it doesn't so it's interesting
that they're so in on this that they're
just like you know what we're buying
them we like what they're working on and
this is a new IP right a lot of us
thought that if you purchase some of
these Studios right and without having a
pre-existing sort of uh relationship
with them maybe it makes sense like you
know what we're planning to bring back
this old you know we're bringing back so
calm we're running back resistance it is
Rip we want you to be the socom team we
want you to be the resistance team
whatever the case may be well the new
Killzone team whatever
um but it's not this is new IP that
they're taking a big risk on so the fact
that they're willing to bring them
in-house before that first game is even
out because we know games in this
multiplayer space service based game
Space
of the vast majority of these games that
are going to come out maybe one or two
survives even if they're all good it's
just a crowded space and you know people
don't have the bandwidth to be on two or
three you know service based games it's
just not the case so bye bye just
process of elimination some of these
games whether they're good or not are
just not gonna make it and the fact that
willing to jump in shows a little bit
about
maybe
PlayStation's desperation in this space
particularly because they're so kind of
far behind the eight ball right they
they got everything else locked down
that single player first person
narrative
but this is different this is different
and every it doesn't matter if you look
at all the failures like you see look at
Ubisoft with the stuff that they've
shuttered before it's even out
everybody's trying to find that one game
that they can they can say is going to
make us money hand over fish we don't
have to worry about it and you know they
keep chasing that bag no matter how many
failures they see in the space because
all you need is one right and I think
that's PlayStation's thinking I think
all we need is one and then that secures
us being able to continue to make these
big single players sort of prestige
games without kind of fear of you know
the money not being there in the interim
you know five or six years seven years
that those games take to make
um so it's interesting that they this is
a pivot by PlayStation yeah in a way we
have not seen before yeah um and it's
interesting because again for those of
those people who love
what they consider PS4 PlayStation right
what they what they morphed into during
the PS4 generation in a lot of ways this
is going to be a different Beast yeah
and I don't know if they can you know I
we'll see we'll see if this if the
prestige game suffer I doubt they will
but you just never know yeah definitely
a change in philosophy we we have to
admit this is not as far as the way
they're acquiring now you know I mean
it's definitely not oh I'll let at it go
on at any bars for fireworks
yeah I I don't think this is the change
of philosophy I I think that Sony has no
choice but to do this they uh
they know they can't keep up with
Microsoft's uh output so they're trying
to you know buy some of these smaller
Studios that they have some form of
relationship with I'm assuming that
Bungie's relationship with these uh with
these developers was able to smooth that
you know top conversation over to have
it done you know I've said for a while
now
if Microsoft's able to get this engine
sending out quality games and they're
able to do it a few times a year
especially with stuff like a valve Fable
outer worlds to hellblade to perfect art
you know and that's just a couple of the
games the State of Decay tuner there to
make these games be very
you know consistent with good quality
Sony can't keep up with that and I think
they know that because
they started these purchases when
Microsoft started buying Studios for
years they didn't really move too much
you know they they'd buy a studio here
and there but after a while after they
bought Bethesda and they bought those
five Studios back then and they bought
Excel entertainment and uh the uh and
obsidian then you started seeing them
okay let's pick up this studio let's
pick up that studio this is reactionary
it's got to be reactionary and they know
for a fact even though if it's not
PlayStation I mean Microsoft they know
they see Netflix out there making moves
they they see other companies picking
stuff up and people are kicking the
tires stuff like Bethesda and Activision
rarely almost never happens people
rarely buy publishers
the only reason Microsoft is able to do
it is because they have an absurd amount
of cash laying around most the time when
these companies come in like Netflix and
trying to like you know get into this
field a little bit they they pick up the
smaller double A Studios and that's what
you're seeing PlayStation do because
they know look we can't compete with
Microsoft if they do do this keep in
mind these let's just do anything small
though there's no one here not small at
all they're like 150 plus they ain't
made a game true but they not a small
team so in that way it is kind of
organic since they are no matter how big
of a studio they are they are they
haven't done it but but in order to this
so they had made a game with Sony on a
second and then Sony comes in afterwards
so this is a definitely a change of
philosophy they've absolutely done this
neither has Bungie done that
but I mean how many studios have they
bought in the past two years they've
bought a lot yeah and that that's my
point like none of this is organic
yeah like you know people sit there and
they say oh you know
they they
they act like Microsoft buying Bethesda
wasn't organic there's literally video
of Phil Spencer being called over
Fallout 76 issue this literally videos
of Todd Howard saying that they wanted
to get more when running and they're
having a hard time and Xbox themselves
helped them do it you know first off
technically if you want to get if you
want to get extremely technical
all the three big platforms excluding
Nintendo to a degree because they don't
really work with third party if they buy
anyone it's organic because they've
worked with them for years you could
even make the argument that it would be
an organic acquisition for Xbox based on
their relationship with the OG Xbox and
Peter Moore and bringing shenmue and
bringing the Sega games over to and
Windows CE being in the Dreamcast you
could even make that auction at this
point it's like I said you know I can
understand with like the magnifying
glass so you know I personally feel like
just because you go into a studio and
you say yo build me a game that's not
organic growth organic growth is
something like Insomniac where they've
where they've worked with them for years
and years they they've really you know
put money into the ecosystem because I
personally feel like in order to be on
that organic level it has to be more
than just money Talent it's got to be
Studios one thing that you can really
put out is you can put Kojima Studio not
only did they generate money for them
like yo here use Horizons engine there
is actual organic growth going on there
but there's some studios that they pick
up they work those one time oh that's
our get shut up but let's get to it
let's get to the court it's just we
going in Let's Stop Dancing let's stop
dancing in two years and say well that's
organic let's get to the quarter issue
let's stuff dance because I know where
you do it and I think I'm doing to it
I'm instigated so my quest the thing is
I think why this organic conversation is
coming this is just what I see a kid and
you can chop in if you like is that what
I see Microsoft making acquisition you
know the thought process oh if the game
is successful then I will see well that
was made before
Microsoft had nothing to do with that
right no you know how it is
last part and then if the game flopped
off of Post acquisition well you know
mess things up the Xbox Stitch she's
like yeah that's the funny thing that I
see the double standard like I said it's
very hilarious to me when I see people
move the goal posts when it comes to
Acquisitions and then the games and the
success of it when it comes to the Xbox
but we gotta keep it true on that I see
that talk so that's why I started to see
this thing well you know the way
somebody does it is it's just the Purity
way this is this is the correct way of
doing it to me an acquisition is an
acquisition period that's it how the
game comes out at that point is how the
game comes out it's just funny these
qualifiers based on success I just think
it's hilarious to me continue I get
annoyed when I see people okay they PL
uh you know obsidian with the outer
worlds and oh yeah this studio yeah made
a fantastic game I can't imagine what
they do if they get more money they say
oh they're just automatic they're gonna
go to [__] yeah we gotta stop with this
Purity talk if they all that matters is
if when a game comes out is it good
yeah nobody cares about that who cares
is the game fire that's it I don't care
where it came from so that that's the
thing that people we have to stop with
all of this Purity talk no one cares
about that you just using it to try to
take credit away from something else
that's all that is continue I got my
rant off it's like crazy like people sit
there you know they want to talk about
mismanagement they want to talk about
Acquisitions this that but then they
they don't want to talk about all the
studios that Sony bought with almost no
working with them they won't talk about
mismanagement and they don't want to
talk about all this issues like days
gone and there's so many mismanagement
that they do but people just simply
don't look at it they shut down multiple
Studios there's issues in general going
on with Sony stuff we literally saw a
massive amount of people leaving naughty
dog in the past like three or four years
like the people that was working on the
last of us too and people sit there act
like that stuff doesn't happen look I
get it there has been issues with some
of Microsoft Studios but when you have
media molecule another one when you have
the the simple amount of of Studios that
Microsoft has Sometimes some of them are
just not gonna go the way the other ones
are going you know what's funny no one
talks about when obsidian has done
nothing but knock out 80s and above the
Metacritic score games no one talks
about
you know all these other games that that
Microsoft is doing that's doing very
well they just want to talk about the
outlines let's talk about Halo for the
18th time and make streams multiple
times and never talk about anything else
that's just Xbox related you know let's
not talk about the the the the amount of
bad PlayStation topics that I can look
through people's Channel and don't see
nothing about any of that it's just
let's talk about Xbox state and leaving
let's talk about you know what's going
on hi-fi rush you know let's let's
completely forget everything else in
Spanish and fairness though the Xbox do
we have it's bad news
if people like to isolate and act like
that's the only thing going on in the
end yeah
because I haven't I'm sorry yeah no
that's it because it happened but I real
quick it just it kind of feels like you
know what it is this is where the
argument comes from that and this is
this is it
the problem is that the status quo of
selling games piecemeal and console
sales and all of that has been attacked
in in in the first real way that it's
ever really been attacked right that's
the only reason that this is happening
when you think about it it's just like
Sony's continuing to sell the way they
sell right but they've had to Pivot into
a space that they are absolutely not
comfortable in because Xbox has made
enough waves in that space to make it so
that they have to Pivot that's the
that's the beef that's where the Purity
comes from nah you know they this is the
way it's always been done
when you think about how pure that
Purity is let's think about it showing
it when Sony came onto the scene they
shuttered Studios they bought Studios
and shuttered them so that they would
not make Sega Saturn ports of certainly
I remember that you said it cut their
business
so it's like let
that Purity is stained with a lot of
blood right there's a lot of blood in
that snow you trying to make it seem
like it was religious wars remember when
they used to burn the books from the
past Generations
we are gods of the Gods
and that's there's a lot there's a lot
of bad business in that Purity and the
funny thing is all these companies do it
and if you flip it if if you flipped it
if the status quo had always been
services from the beginning Atari sold
me a subscription service and then all
of a sudden Xbox decided now but sell
you this for seventy dollars
the argument would be the same all these
companies all these companies
that annoys me I agree it's just like
look like
I understand when people sit there and
they say
I have gave Microsoft to benefit out too
many times and they could be frustrated
absolutely absolutely that is
understandable I say every time don't
don't go off with any influencer says
jump off any podcast or any media Outlet
if you feel on if you feel like
Microsoft has burned your trust too many
times wait for the games then jump on
board yeah absolutely what what kills me
is like if something happens I don't
talk about it to something else happens
like the ABK deal we don't talk about
unless another news story that is worth
talking about happens but what kills me
is people will talk about the output of
games on Xbox every week acting like
Microsoft can fix it in a week
they've had plenty of time to fix it and
you know we can't act like the pandemic
didn't happen that slowed the
progression down we get it you don't got
to keep talking about it
to me if PlayStation had that many lit
games white people talking about Xbox 24
7. let's not do it let's be let's be
nice no we ain't being nice I've been
nice to be respectful be respectful
um King you've been patient my man ain't
getting his balls off today I feel he
ain't getting a chance to talk the way
he talked no it's just that um Sony had
five billion dollars for Acquisitions
and they made Acquisitions it's just um
they looked over at who was performing
what and they see a game that probably
that they feel is gonna fit fit that uh
that little yeah
um service thing that they're trying to
do the 25 games
um
they can't afford bleeding edges right
they can't afford it
bleeding edge wasn't a bad game but you
know it didn't perform the engagement
yeah right you know so same thing with
law Breakers you know they can't afford
these these games of service that don't
make it they need an apex you know they
need a pub G they need a fortnight they
need something that's that's going to
give reoccurring money because they
notice now more than ever
that Call of Duty is not going to be
right so they have to go out and make
another Cash Cow and I know I heard
Sovereign said something about oh they
can have the studio do Socom or they can
have the studio do this
they want new IP fresh blood in this
space right and and any point in time
they can go back in a hat to to do those
old IPS but they're not at uh DEFCON 5
right now right right you know they're
they're still trying to figure it out so
while we have Microsoft stalled over
there you know we we made a Ruckus we
have everybody looking over there let's
go acquire this stuff right now and
let's let's get these people to get
these games out before Microsoft
actually turns this machine on and these
games just overwhelm us right so
they will talk all this gossip and they
really be acting like none of these
games are ever gonna come out like these
games are gonna sit in limbo for the
rest of Eternity we're never gonna see
Fable we're never gonna see the outer
worlds too look if you want to talk
smacks on these games when these games
come out if they're bad I'm right there
with you I'm right in line right behind
you with my ticket saying let's go but
it's just like people have too much to
say on games they ain't never even seen
people have too much to say on games
that that don't even care about
people want to talk
I don't care I mean that kind of stuff
doesn't bother me but I feel like you
get your balls off you know for me look
I'm Wade King I think that to me this is
this is a lot of reactive moves and what
it signifies to me shout out to first of
all whatever Saudi scene with firewall
must have impress the hell out of them
like they must have been blown away and
and in this climate before that just
scared someone else's gonna buy them no
five no but that's part of it right like
like you know if you see something that
could be the next big thing right and we
got to give sodi this
they always have their finger on the
pulse of what's popping we cannot take
seafood or every look at all the little
strains whatever whatever they put their
little exclusive bag towards that I
don't like you know I know addict don't
like it but we have to give them credit
when it comes to being able to see
what's going on I don't mind them doing
it my issues them acting like a victim
doing it and I'm gonna give you that too
I'm gonna give you that too so so
basically what it is is they see it so
whatever they see shout out to Five Spot
that listen they got Triple A Talent
over there Tony in that team they got
like Destiny experience all day the
other day belt um Apex Legend Mass
Effect experience Halo experience like
these guys know how to do multiplayer
and to me I Gotta Give Standing Ovation
to Sony on this thank you this is what
I'm talking y'all know I'm Lord
acquisition this is what I'm talking
about stop going up there crying like
there's nothing we can do if we don't
have Call of Duty in the history of
gamings this is the Sony I want to see
go out there and show me that you are
going to take multiplayer game serious
we get I give Xbox all the smoke when
hashtags just won
he said fingers he doesn't listen I give
it because I'm like look Microsoft you
need one of them hashtag just one third
person over the shoulder narrative
bangers that's a new IP I'm always gonna
be on but the same energy I am going to
be on Sony you guys created so calm
y'all had a resistance y'all had all
this stuff under your belt and then once
y'all made just once all of a sudden
y'all stop and what happened is I buy
Pig King they got comfortable they
thought there was nothing ever going to
change this Call of Duty situation the
way they position like look we get their
marketing rights right people just off
marketing alone and we do our little
practices with exclusive contented maps
and guns and by default you're gonna
think Call of Duty is the place to play
on playstation you can't tell me we've
already heard on record when the
announcement happened there were secret
meetings that Sony like yo what are we
going to do here this is a this is a
scenario we could not Envision happening
that we are going to lose we're not
going to lose it it's still going to be
on a platform but basically it being in
game pass it to them is the equivalent
of losing the marketing rights and the
marketing and and like the Zeitgeist of
yo could you imagine like we said the
Call of Duties is the series s packaging
you're going to change the conversation
but that's a huge blow to them that's
why we were surprised Ohio not to
mention given that much power to Xbox
negotiation yes so to me if I'm if I'm
looking from the outside in you can't
tell me that Bungie
yes these deals were made you know it
talks for years in advance or whatever
but you can't tell me it wasn't
accelerated once they heard that that
the Activision Blizzard King thing was
about to happen as far as to finalize
the bungee deal you can't tell me that
this is not a response as well you know
they are looking to to Really suppress
somebody to really improve their
multiplayer catalog and I think this is
dope this is what I want to see from
Sony now not this excuse stuff that I
was I was hearing about I know Jim's got
to do what Jim's got to do for the
stakeholders kind of thing but that's it
I mean other than that you know I would
just say I do see a shift in philosophy
as far as the um the Acquisitions you
know as far as what I said uh Bungie and
firewall Savage Haven even Nixon either
yeah they're not done so to me this is
them putting themselves in position we
know about the 10 live service games
look all it takes is one of those to hit
and if they have one of those hitting
under their Banner you know in in the
Sony ecosystem that's huge and I think
that's what they're kind of good attic
is all right
these two platforms are building their
Stables to go into a subscription war
that that that's what realistically
what's going on here sure it's not gonna
happen anytime soon but eventually
everything's going to be on a TV and you
just get a controller and play it I mean
we have a lot of Internet structures to
work on on that but they they know the
direction this stuff is going you know I
think Microsoft is jumping out the
window a little bit earlier than all the
other platforms but they know what's
going on and in order to to fuel that
kind of War you're going to need games
you're going to need a massive amount of
games yes look at Netflix look how long
it took Netflix to dig out of debt to
some degree it took them years to do
that because they've been funding their
own content and and sooner or later
you're going to have these going on and
I think that's one of the things that
PlayStation knows like look do we really
want them to have Call of Duty as a
stable because stuff might be right now
where it's more beneficial for Microsoft
to have Call of Duty on the PlayStation
platform but you don't know how the
Landscaping of the gaming industry is
going to be changed bro you know
something could have happened where
Microsoft could see more money in
holding that brand on their own walls
than letting other people come across
the walls and that's what PlayStation is
scared of the most and I think
PlayStation also knows what king used to
call it bad business practices with the
exclusive stuff look the third party
exclusive deal stuff you know that that
that's cool that that it brings people
you know to your platform and you know
stuff like that but you can't tell me
that ownership isn't better
like if you own the building I just I
think it's a little it's a little you
have more control of where things are
going to go and I think Sony there is a
change of a lot like they are owning
they are trying to own now they're
they're making Acquisitions and to me
what it it shows the notes is that a
there's a potential that they feel that
okay we've pushed and scratched and
kicked the scratch with this Activision
Blizzard King thing long enough most
likely it's going down we're gonna make
it as hard as we can for them all the
way to the end but most likely it's
going to and if it's going down okay we
got Bungie over here 10 live service
games help us out we got fire walk over
here whatever we saw this is fire this
is underneath the Sony PlayStation
Studios logo we got something we got
facts it's that you got to build up your
resources your Warheads in this or this
this part that you're super deficient
they've been deficient I've been saying
that for a long time and that's what I
want to see guys and this is the tip of
the iceberg because we talked about it
last week or the week before where
they're making bigger moves into the
cloud space yeah they realize that they
have to be there you got to understand
that Microsoft was kind of already there
because of what Microsoft does not
because of because of Xbox Xbox being
being privy to that stuff it's just that
it's kind of part of the equation
because they're part of Microsoft but
Microsoft they're moving to Cloud was
because of Microsoft stuff right Xbox
was kind of an afterthought in that
regard and it works beautifully but at
the end of the day that's why I said
like now that Google's out there free
agent nobody's using their Tech [__]
they're not they're not going to shutter
the tech completely they spend X how
many billions of dollars on that Tech I
could see Sony going to Google but like
hey let's partner up yeah yeah I can see
that because you notice ever since that
initial Talk of the Azure Microsoft and
Sony partnership we haven't seen any
progress anymore and especially since
the Activision Blizzard thing all of a
sudden you don't hear about this
partnership exactly the relationship
could be strange yeah say the least and
you know they could pivot to another
partner and what bet again Google is one
of the few opposing the deals that's
what happened yeah six months ago
absolutely no and that makes a hell of a
lot of sense because Google regardless
to what them realizing that they didn't
want to do this on their own makes a
whole lot of sense it was oh that Tech
was always going to end up someplace
else and if I'm Sony I'm like what
better place than Sony because I'm gonna
tell you this right now that Stadium
from a technical storm fire fire fire
the technology when we think about the
three sort of services that really are
doing it it's Nvidia yes G-Force down
fire G-Force now fire
in terms of quality yeah and then right
below it is Xbox right yes I would give
that
um yeah so if Sony you have to think
about the cloud stuff because that's
where all of these games
remember all of these games don't mean
nearly as much the multiplayer ones
don't mean nearly as much if you're only
opening up the ecosystem to PC proper
like download right the cloud stuff is
where they have to be and when you talk
about the deficiencies sure on the game
side the deficiencies all those
multiplayer games those service based
games
bigger than that is the deficiency cloud
and when you look at all the deals that
Microsoft have just said they're going
to make in order to put their games in
addition to ABK games onto all these
other freaking platforms that many of us
have never even heard of
it that to me is where somebody's like
okay no no we have to we have to Pivot
we have to so the philosophy has changed
AJ like it it hap it has but like I said
before they've been forced to do it well
that's what I said yeah I said the
philosophy hasn't changed they've been
forced to change the way they do things
because I mean look look look what's
going on like everyone's being bought by
everyone we literally had four three or
four acquisition stuff that's going on
it's not just little people but like
these big massive corporations Sega
bought Angry Birds for some reason
so much consolidation
yeah you see race around race outside
tension out here and this is the thing
like it's just to me it that's just the
nature of it right so when we talk about
the consolidation that this is just it
they they had to Pivot and react to that
because everybody's Consolidated they're
gonna be left with nobody that's why I
was laughing at all this organ had it
growth stuff because I'm like the last
five things they did was not organic
like firewalk oh what is it a bungee
Haven Savage Nexus
and it makes sense though I'm not even
clowning like it makes sense yeah with
Nexus you got to fortify your PC
relationship as much as PlayStation fans
was giving us a whole bunch of things we
said these games are coming to PC which
they are right you need a studio that
has this experience in making these
ports of your quote-unquote bangers to
get that Revenue Sony's not stupid
they're not paying attention to people's
ego and Purity talk and all that they
trying to make money period so it's
gonna happen they just gonna grease you
along the way ladies you feel that yeah
we're exclusive and all this and then
you gonna get greased into where the
money goes
make no mistake they're gonna sell you
70 game games for as long as they can
for as long as they can they like this
is a seven dollar product this is what
it is these companies about making money
period all this talk I'm done anybody
else got this stuff no it's just it's it
is what it is it's gonna be interesting
because I think finally this year we're
going to start seeing the fruits of this
labor and I want to see again the
PlayStation faithful the ones who to
them PS4 that generation and what they
turned into is what the PlayStation is
you're gonna have a rude awakening and
again you you've been you you should
have been kind of acclimated to it
already you know the PC stuff whatever
the day and date this is going to be a a
pivot
if you haven't seen and I just again
because I'm all I'm old I'm all in for
change I Love Changes good pivot yo
that's why I blowing acquisition this is
a good pivot it makes the movie
well-rounded yes you better get up on
this Cloud you better get up on this
mobile you had to get up on this PC the
market the gate the sphere is changing
and if you don't evolve you are going to
get left behind what they're doing with
the old model is spectacular they're
making sales after sales they're
breaking records the PS4 is I get it but
the market is going to change 5-10 years
down the road and if you're not equipped
if you don't have your ducks in a row
for the long term you will get left
behind and it's good to see them making
it especially multi-player games thank
you please please and they're already
behind it let's go they're behind the
eight ball already they have to rush yes
they kind of have to like yes you know
they make no mistake in that realm they
are behind the eight ball so yeah no
they're doing the right thing salute to
them so that's what I got anything else
we move on super chats all that oh if
you want to do Super Chat specific to
this topic before we just do this yes
okay so let's go let me go back a little
bit
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey now in regards to Hi-Fi Russia's
success while sales are still important
as y'all have stated my opinion is as
long as the game is fun that is success
in my book as a game player
it should be don't worry about all the
conversation around it you having fun
that's what matters that is in reality
that's what matters the facts
then we have Stitch remember for two
years five dollar Super Chat I think R
Kelly is in solitary confinement because
he hasn't said anything about this
acquisition or is it because this was
not organic
the Kells you got kills keep it in the
closet keep it in the classes
and we got Joe Repco AKA blame remember
for 30 months long that's finest good
afternoon IOP hope everyone is having a
great weekend I hope to see at least one
of you hint hint in duveri in Warframe
this Wednesday is somebody somebody
being forced to play wolf you talking to
y'all
that Warframe attic was good attic was
good
yeah
uh there we have Carl Andrews Junior two
dollars for chat too many being bought
or wanting to be bought it is just the
nature of where we're at right now right
you know listen you you would love for
every Studio to be able to subsist on
their own no overseers but the fact of
the matter is that's just not the can't
just can't
Eternal should die two dollars chats
firewalk Studios is the new organic keto
Studio
yo that's messy that is messy continue
and we have Mandingo mcdickins remember
for two years twenty dollar Super Chat
so y'all got love for the Nigerian polar
bears but what about the mandingos so
we're a little bulky in the middle whoa
we deserve some love too five dollar
donation whoa you go ahead save those
mandingas
[Laughter]
somebody buying a blank canvas half the
painting set yeah I mean they like what
they saw apparently so you know let me
tell y'all that game has to be fire for
them to buy the studio after just seeing
it and they could have just did what
they normally do let them publish it you
know let the game come on let the game
come out they like no no no nobody
getting this we want this be on the
lookout for whatever firework I'm very
impressed to see what yeah I think they
they know they have their fingernail
touch yeah Haven as well again yes they
don't know what it is but salute all
right then we have Robert Kelly again
two dollar stupid chat R.I.P to
Evolution uh media molecule Liverpool
and gorilla Cambridge yes episode that
see but these are Studios that they had
in the fold again didn't do what they
were supposed to do media molecules
still here though they're not going
nowhere they're making a game so you
know R.I.P the dreams though but yeah
absolutely absolutely
Xbox pivoted first people wasn't buying
Xbox games so no sequels besides Halo
gears and Forza since people didn't want
to buy Xbox games Xbox was like K will
rent new games on the service yeah I
don't know that's yeah I've said that
like I don't know yeah I don't I don't
get to the point here face because I
that's what I say
well I said that I said PlayStation
pivoted right but they pivoted yeah they
pivoted because Xbox forced them to
Pivot right they that's just what it is
because if Game Pass wasn't nearly as
successful as it has been they'd see no
reason to even dip their toes in this in
this in this Service river in the
service there's no reason for it gotcha
um we got heartbeat Cindy remember for
one year five dollar Super Chat so is
PlayStation desperate or the acquisition
was already planned either way the
industry is changing and it's much more
exciting things are changing that is
changes is scary but it is very
interesting to see because yeah I think
yeah I think it's reactive as well you
know to lock it down just in case yeah I
don't know that the acquisition was
already planned but again they're not
stupid like they knew they haven't they
had a deficiency in that anyway and all
of these companies no matter what
company you have somebody at some point
in time white boarded a service based
game with microtransactions it's just
what it is
so you know everybody wants that cash
cow
Nintendo on the otaku five dollar Super
Chat reminder that Nintendo don't need
Acquisitions Xbox needs 33 Studios to
match their output these damn still
trying to catch up to Nintendo's oldest
teams uh shout out to Nintendo we gotta
get Nintendo
yeah they just they they are they kind
of recession-proof
they've got their niche they got they
they've locked down they they have good
output can't say anything about Nintendo
for and they've shown they can be
successful but I'll call it dirty houses
their whole business doesn't go down
because they don't have the Call of Duty
he said the PlayStation would die
Jesus ah then we have Grumble Grumble
two dollars is Cliffy B making a service
game for Xbox
no I think Cliffy when he talked about
the law Breakers thing apparently he
found out who has the ownership rights
the ownership of of law Breakers he's
like bring it back
um I think I think we're caught up all
right now you said you had a Nintendo
aspect they're mad at me because I don't
have enough room
so they like why is it
so real quick Nintendo the Nintendo
Indie showcase that happened uh this
week um I'm going to I'm going to get
into it and there's not a whole lot of
stuff that I was excited about
but I'm gonna pivot into something else
that uh the Dukes talked about I haven't
had a chance to actually listen but it
was very interesting to see
um yeah so the Nintendo Indie showcase
happened earlier this week and you know
again small games things that that were
cool for me that I saw was um with the
cat simulator no not the cat simulator
Calico no I don't want to see that
um the rift of the necro dancer seemed
cool just because the Crypt of the necro
dancer was kind of like a like a like a
rhythm-based sort of Dungeon Crawler
when you had to like move in in sort of
tone and sort of a rhythm with with the
music which is very cool Rift to the
necro dancer feels more like uh it's a
rhythm game but it's a bunch of
different stuff like At first I looked
at the trailer and it looked like it was
like a Guitar Hero okay and then it
looked like it was some other stuff so
it kind of feels like it's taking that
sort of core type of game playing
applying it to different scenarios which
which seems kind of cool
um then we saw animal well which we saw
shout out to addict and and donkey's
game yeah we covered it at Pax yeah
shared memory in big mode
um it's animal well so that's coming to
the switch
um in addition to that I don't know if
any of you guys ever played Tesla Grand
Tesla grad was a very cool sort of uh
kind of physics based puzzle platformer
back in the day it was like a it was
like a freaking uh it was a mobile game
then it went to switch kind of around
the the launch year of switch
um so they they kind of Shadow dropped
the remaster of that in addition to the
sequel um these puzzle-based sort of uh
physics-based uh I know the first one
had a lot to do with electricity Tesla
um so they kind of Shadow dropped both
of those games on the day of the thing
and then Blasphemous Blasphemous was a
very cool kind of not simplistic but it
was a is a very cool metroidvania that
came out on multiple platforms I played
it on switch
um that had kind of like Metroid videos
aspects to it very sort of dark uh
medieval sort of overtones to it
religious overtones very religious all
right yeah um the sequel the sequel is
coming out um they got the announcement
trailer
they really expanded upon it animation
this looks fine it looks Bonkers right
so that I'm excited for that hopefully I
uh but the one that really stuck out to
me let's get it
oxen free too lost signals
um I think anybody who played the first
oxen free and saw this and then was like
oh cool this game's coming out I'm gonna
play this on my Xbox
was shocked to find out that this game
is coming to every platform Under the
Sun including Mack
and and not the Xbox which the original
enjoyed a period of exclusivity on when
it first came out and I don't know when
the first one came off I forgot I
remember I remember seeing a preview of
it from uh Marty sleva when he was still
with IGN that's that's how long ago this
was um this game enjoyed I don't know if
it was a year maybe six months to a year
exclusive on Xbox it was I remember it
was huge because it was a really cool
story based uh sort of uh uh kind of
kind of in the vein of old school
adventure games but the the selling
point was really like the the the the
dialogue and the conversations were we
felt really organic and felt like there
were really two people having a
conversation and the story was really
cool it was about ghosts
um and to see it now finally the sequel
so many years later to come out because
this was this was an Xbox One game yeah
um two sequel come out is exciting but
it is disappointing that it's missing
Xbox and Netflix has it though Netflix
has it right so so there is an argument
to be made that maybe you know the
service based movie guys don't want to
put their game on another service quote
unquote service based platform but again
you could choose to sell it a la carte
on Xbox I don't necessarily see the what
the issue there is it's weird and again
it points to something that uh I just
saw the Duke's thumbnail and it made me
laugh because I'm like there's there's
more games apart from obviously the
Final Fantasy 7 remake the Final Fantasy
16 there are other games that are just
missing Xbox
um the um the recent re-release of the
Mega Man Battle Network games are
completely missing Xbox right
beyond that we talked about a octopath
too and things of that nature so it's
just interesting and we talk again attic
has his feelings on on why Square Enix
does it but it is interesting that it's
happening in other sort of spaces
including spaces that are not Eastern
Studios right if there is if they're
playing Square this time exactly if
there is a thinking that there might be
some Eastern bias right with the with
the American-made console manufacturer
okay or started the trend I could
totally blame them oh this is what it is
it influences everybody else yeah the
influence everybody else so it is weird
that this is the case so I want to know
what you guys feel about this
specifically about oxen free tube right
because of because of the Legacy what is
it the the yeah the Legacy that it has
on Xbox
um and everything else the kind of this
general idea that beyond the square in
this conversation it just games missing
Xbox for apparently no real legitimate
reason other than oh well you're not
getting it because like I said Oxford 2
is coming to the Mac
like come on man add that flicks and
Netflix and then we're gonna get they
own it now so I you know I get it what
do y'all think big addict any thoughts
no it's just the fact that um if it
wasn't coming to Game Pass I really
don't care
what is the answer to everything
it's you know um these Xbox dudes act
like they are old something we had it
first before over here with us and it
was uh it was expensive to us on the
launch and we we we should have it you
don't own them you don't have it shut up
that's it so you know if they own them
then they can dictate what they can do
you don't own them this is the reason
why these guys are going out inquiring
people because
when it's all said and done whatever
game you're working on can that
oh so you just want to have to take over
yeah they did it rainfall you had a
PlayStation version
so are you saying that since xBox wasn't
popular on the playground they went and
took their ball and went home and then
they and then they bought the ball
manufacturer
for for whatever reason
certain games are missing Xbox yes that
is cool
I have witnessed the petty of Microsoft
continue to move how the way you're
moving and you your key card won't work
one morning
purchase you'll be purchased it's as
simple as that so after this acquisition
is done and after little this little
dude over here buying up all types of oh
okay so okay
he's in this shopping literally with a
hundred dollars and buying a whole bunch
of Penny Canyons
Petty Candy Studio don't do this and and
as soon as Microsoft finishes with the
APK deal okay because they get on their
eyes are the problem yeah yeah see like
yo y'all buy little Studios
Microsoft goes and by publishers
right you'll go and rent out uh an
apartment in the building and Microsoft
goes and buys the projects
I just say keep on doing what you're
doing uh
when you wake up in the morning
your key card don't work
and you get a new badge that says
Microsoft
to the faucets in King's house run
caught coding the game fast fat okay
okay
when they hand you this welcome to death
row
but you know there's an argument to be
made that they could overwhelm them with
all these little you know all these
little babies
yeah Pacquiao was supposed to overwhelm
Floyd
baby Golems yesterday now they were
beating up on the on the walls yeah they
didn't make the game fun no no exactly
they end up just like I said they're
gonna be an app all right the reason why
you're gonna be an app is as I predict
you could have a lot of um law Breakers
you can have a lot of bleeding edge and
you can't recover from that you can't
make those games and recover from that
you can't make those games invest all
that time and think it's gonna happen
for you you're looking for a lotto
ticket it's cool
but you can't afford it take your last
ten dollars and go buy ten dollars a
lotto tickets what you gotta eat oh
right so keep doing what you're doing
you're gonna wind up a nap
just to be clear just to be clear so
basically Xbox is is allowing these
little deals for Saudi and everyone else
you're not allowing anything okay
Microsoft can't do anything right now oh
okay because they focus on Jim is Jim is
a masterful chess player I'm gonna keep
them tied up over here right while I go
and do as much as I can
to get all these Studios under our
Banner or we can move forward Sony can
go make all the little Acquisitions they
want they're not buying no Publishers
right Microsoft is so they have to go in
front of the FTC they have to go to CMA
they got to do all these things uh Sony
just go through here's a check all right
y'all Tuesday
and that's it you know so listen
he's smart they're both smart it's just
who gambles pays out in the end right I
know Sony can't say we got 10 games of
services and
they have misses right they can't have
misses they got to have hits got you
okay now you're saying based on the
scale because and according to what
Hogue does agree with you in the sense
that you know once um the ABK is
finished they are not stop or something
with the acquisition so according to you
all all resources are dedicated there
they're the suit is that that they're
gonna come back outside and they won't
scoop up and Devoe ball situation yeah
okay and it's a small business versus
Big Bang versus little bag that's what
we know that's it
billion dollar company oh okay I see
what we do I just want to be clear
addict your thoughts on this uh sir
I think these Indie developers are
holding their game hostage looking for
that game pass back oh they did take the
first that's what I think that is I
think uh because it's it's not a
coincidence it's on every other platform
uh but this particular one I think the
Square Enix things a little bit
different because I do think there is
some relationship going on between Sony
and Playstation uh even if the game pass
back was there I I don't know if Square
would take it at this point because I
think that they're building up for
something like I said I think they're
trying to be bought but you know at the
end of the day
uh I do think the Mega Man same scenario
you know we could release this game now
uh while it's going on the PlayStation
we don't know if we could uh you know
make that money right up front or we
could hold a hostage for six months
until uh you know Microsoft needs some
more games to come to their game pass
get that back and the original sales
most likely who's going to get anyway
right I think that's probably happening
here too because it's going on Netflix
Netflix
what if that what if Netflix is applying
you know opposing Services strategies
and that's the thing like you know again
if they unless Microsoft came with
PlayStation has their own too they got
PlayStation Plus this has its own
subscription service but it isn't it
isn't it still isn't the same it still
isn't you know first party game day and
date they don't feel you but that's not
a first party game so there's no real
realistic reason to hold that if you're
not it to me if it was that a pure
subscription standpoint they would treat
both equally sure Game Pass is probably
a little bit bigger like like perception
wise than than PlayStation Plus but I
would say PlayStation Plus actually has
more people sub to it because they
merged them all together right to me
besides the Square Enix things and
remember we we set a cut like a year ago
when this started happening with little
games because we started seeing a lot of
these you know Japanese titles skip the
Xbox platform I said then just tell them
not to work with them and you guys don't
know we need the Final Fantasy games you
know my issue with what's going on with
uh Playstation and Final Fantasy isn't
with any individual thing it's how
PlayStations trying to paint themselves
like they don't do it that's why I'm
like you know if I if I can choose not
PlayStation I'm gonna choose not
PlayStation but it's just like if this
is the case and people are looking at
this and seeing the kind of bags that
Microsoft is throwing out there to get
these type of games and Game Pass I do
think it's possible that some of these
like look it's going to take us probably
two years to make that kind of money
when we can just hold off for six months
and get that money right now so so
question and this this is jumping into
the next topic but
whatever Joe Staton is making for them
is is a third party it's not you know
it's not Netflix exclusive it's gonna be
everywhere as well
and it's a triple A game it's gonna be a
triple it's not going to be oxen free
touch you that's on Xbox
oh so you think statins game will be
okay
I'm just thinking they're looking I'm
thinking they're looking at it from a a
scale of the game you know if it's
Triple A game that they feel like they
could sell on the platform very easily
then they'll do it but I feel like even
though that the first one was mildly
successful you know a lot of people love
that game they're looking at it from
what can we expect from it in the sea of
competition this year because this isn't
an easy year to go through next year
isn't an easy year to go through and
they see that potential bag that I'm
definitely gonna get all got to do is
weigh it out Microsoft in the bag that I
potentially might get uh you know people
want their money up front and if they
have to wait six months to get it
they'll get it I guarantee you within a
year Mega Man will be on Xbox
uh and it's because these companies you
saw it with the Japanese like the amount
of money that Microsoft probably spun
out to get all these games the Final
Fantasy one uh ten nine seven the uh the
Dragon Quest 11 like you know uh there's
some some of the tales games were on
there the amount of money that Microsoft
spent definitely wasn't not noticed
people look at oh yo yo he said yo
Microsoft gave you how much money so do
you think they painted themselves into a
corner a little bit by a little bit like
these bags like nobody wants to deal
with them up front now
Game Pass has done a lot of good for
Microsoft it's put a lot of especially
uh you know Community wise it's been
very consumer friendly but I do think
there is a little bit of a double-edged
sword going on that people don't talk
about Game Pass is starting to hurt them
not necessarily as much as it's helping
them but it is starting it's like you
know you're trying to stop a blade and
that double edge is cutting you a little
bit and I think this is one of the the
things that's happening where it's like
look like you know some of these people
because
these little projects occupied traveler
too you know I think uh that might come
into Xbox I don't know if it will but
some of these smaller projects here
notice they don't hold none of the big
stuff Big Stuff always comes
this is the little projects you know
besides the Final Fantasy 7 remake and
stuff it's just the big stuff the small
stuff that doesn't come the stuff that
they know they're gonna have some form
of a community but they're Unsure how
much they're realistically going to sell
what makes more sense to you trying to
you know promote put the game on sale or
just wait six months till Microsoft's
looking for some Game Pass games and
take the check then get that double they
probably already have an Xbox support
already ready
Gotta See You Gotta See yeah I don't
know I think this is I could see them
making the Xbox port and they'd be like
well we need help with the port knowing
it's already done
the king did you get your balls off for
this topic yeah okay sorry
um yeah no I don't really have much to
say other than um yes it is strange that
is not on the uh Xbox platform yes
Netflix owns the studio
yes it's on every other platform right
was it switch PC you know and yes Oxford
free one was on Game Pass very
interesting to me I don't know what to
make of this you know I mean other than
yeah it's not Square
um I don't know the only thing I mean
briefly talked about on Duke with Maddie
was just that I was thinking from the
standpoint of kind of like what addicts
saying if they got the bag the first
time around
and you know it was definitely to their
liking that kind of a bit you know is it
something that look it takes two to
tango on this type of situation so is it
something that you know they may have
priced themselves out they wanted
another game pass bag and Microsoft says
Hey based about metrics last time this
is where we're at and they were like
okay now we good you know what I'm
saying we we want it here and we have
this other all the other platforms to to
um to kind of you know match that so I
don't know the truth is going to come
out on this one I do I am curious though
if it's six months or two a year after
if oxygen free you know two ever comes
to the platform that's gonna be very
interesting to me in the time frame
within there because I am curious with
the subscription service thing if that
plays any factor in it because I don't
know what their situation was in Oxford
free one when were they acquired that's
the other thing I don't know it's not
too long ago oh so it is reset it is
recent yeah let me check yeah that's
that's the question I I you know I don't
know but we're gonna see this is a very
it is a very very strange situation I
will say that but that's all I got
unfortunately you know let me see what's
going on with that and we got it's just
like one of those things like I said I I
do personally feel like if it is The
Game Pass thing which you know we don't
know I wouldn't be surprised if it's the
Game Pass thing and like the executives
at these companies aren't even telling
anyone the reason they're like you know
what if we hold out Microsoft's
eventually going to come looking they're
eventually like they gotta they gotta
feed the beasts I mean they are
considered you know one of the Premier
you know services to compete and we hear
we've heard the talk of language in
contracts that it cannot be in Game Pass
we've heard that talk before I don't
know you know I'm very curious and then
we're going to transition to the state
today because it makes sense but before
we do that let's get these uh super
chats or anything so I wanted to say
before you move on yeah give me a second
no doubt no doubt
shout out to the wondering Dutch oxen
free did one million in sales on Xbox
and steam then three million players on
Game Pass interesting so man sounds
pretty decent in the in those three
million people can potentially buy the
sequel true I mean again negotiations
bro right what if you know oxen free
says hey we did this well but now we
should get this back Madison was like
if the negotiations was have
what what was okay you didn't secure the
bag for the game to come in Game Pass so
we just rip it from the platform you
know what that's why I don't think even
a negotiation was made because to me you
can't you can't have a negotiation like
that then say you know what we taking
our bomb going home and then come back
six months and say yo we want a bag
actually wow
I guess I'm just confused because it's
like they're not going to do a port at
all outside of Game Pass
right so to me it's like okay you're not
even gonna Port it over so to me you
your evaluation that it doesn't make
sense
to go on to the Xbox platform without
Gamepad that's again that's what I'm
assuming that's what it screams to me so
I still feel there may be a breakdown in
negotiation on that or someone is
overvalued themselves or undervaluing
the others then at that point I'm gonna
be royalty Microsoft needs to tell these
people we're not making your game on our
platform at all and maybe because if
they if we have too many of these Domino
effects where companies feel like
they're better off just holding their
game off of the platform Microsoft needs
to take a stand so with your game's not
coming on well and what if the gift of
the curse like you said is this is the
result what if my what if the gift of
the curses that they gave these bags
early in the game pass cycle right when
game passes and people was expecting
that same number and those are like yo
bro this is what you really we really
feel you are right now and dudes are
like nah we not doing it unless you give
us that exact bag or higher and
Microsoft's all right cool there we good
then we won't see you on the platform
until you ready to come back and
negotiate it I'm very curious is how
that's fixed how that's remedy like I
don't know I don't even know of a
circumstance because if you do tell
certain people yo we're not gonna I
think it would have to be one of those
things that I know would be devastating
but it's like do you do it individually
or do you publishing wise okay you know
you're not giving us your smaller gains
we're not going to take your bigger
games but who does that hurt us true but
also it's just like how do you fix that
or Microsoft could say okay you fronting
on us now
come November
game APK deal is done we now get an
influx of 30 to 50 million now
subscribers knowing that Call of Duty is
down to play on Game Pass now we come
back oxen free three we got I'm just
making up a number 150 million Game Pass
subscribers oh you don't want your game
to be seen by 150 50 million off the rip
that changes negotiation posture now
they come in with a position to strength
you see what I'm saying I feel like
exposure would definitely be a sign to
continue the conversation but they're
going to want that money at the end
right but and and if you have 150
million and you've grown your brand off
this much off your own stuff at that
point because the Call of Duty and stuff
I feel like their backs are lowering
because it's like dude we got what we
need to make sure like now we was going
to give you let's say three million six
months ago now it's 10 because we don't
need you anymore like that's that's the
power of negotiations right where people
are in a position to strength based on
exclusivity and popular popularity of
their title versus Microsoft in a
position to strength hey this this is
our user base this is how many people
will instantly download this game and
get this you're gonna your little game
will be on the main storefront next to a
Call of Duty next door whatever so it's
negotiation on both sides it takes two
these are good points we got to see I'm
very curious
Acquisitions it's extremely important
for Microsoft because if people are
going to places
we don't know people are low-key holding
these games hostage but if they're going
to do that Microsoft needs to start
playing horror
buy the building if nobody want to play
nice but you own it okay you don't want
your indicator on our platform
we're going to launch three games with
them you know my people people always
say yo Microsoft got all this money what
you want to do that ain't gonna do
something yo yo imagine imagine a
playing Hardball they're like Okay We're
not gonna put oxy whatever the game's
caught in place this is the original one
they're like okay
not only are we not giving you money for
Game Pass we launching three of our
games the day your game comes out
that's super Petty but but I'm I'm this
industry they they respect that stuff
like they they if you can't give them
money to get them on the platform
because it's not enough what do you do
to get them to not put skip your
platform because at the end of the day
it's not even the game pass it's the
issue it's the fact that it's not coming
to the platform at all no that's a fact
that's
and it could be a bad domino effect we
can end up this being way bad in like
six months to a year I don't know I mean
we don't realistically know what's going
on they've made tremendous strides with
getting third-party games now day in day
into Game Pass like we're seeing low
long lies of PE we're seeing games that
are now like yo they getting third party
so I think it is improving but we're
still seeing these little outliers here
and there like there's pixel McMaster
octopath that could lead up to it too
where people are seeing wulong get these
kind of bags I want that bag I don't
want this bag I want that bad yeah
Michael be like well you ain't got and
they're like well we can't give you that
back then you don't get my game there
you go anyway let's move off let's get
this uh Super Chat sir okay we have one
second we got a bunch that came in
afterwards
pragmatic Eagle remember for two years
twenty dollar Super Chat I'm loving
every game I play and I'm loving aisle
peace
I got Nintendo on the otaku five dollars
Super Ten I ain't gonna cap I wasn't
feeling most of the Indie World
Blasphemous Rift of the necrodancer
bomber cyberfunk which I forgot yeah Jet
Set Vibes and oxen free 2 were the
standouts yep that's about salute screw
it yeah the rest of that stuff was hot
trash yes then we got Robert Kelly
two dollars for the chat Xbox the second
class citizen of game
wow wow sometimes it feels that way yeah
we got uh GSD getting stuff done
remember for one year two dollars Knicks
win Nick's win all right all right right
well that play up hotness maybe I'll
watch a basketball game now
[Music]
announced by Sony in 2021 is it a
surprise that it isn't coming to Xbox
I'd be surprised if somebody blocked
that one up from Xbox but you never know
oh so the acquisition happened September
2021.
um but not even two years not even two
years okay it's enough time to to change
things though yeah for sure
uh because I'm wondering how long it
realistically told that game to be made
damn like I said the original came out
was an Xbox One game so they took
forever
they also did that other what was the I
forgot what it was called there was some
game where you were like uh playing a
drinking game against the devil oh yeah
I forgot about that game yeah I remember
that game oh it was called yeah
um Spartan goes 17 Tupac Super Chat all
these languages and attic chose to speak
fast oh they love it actually I love a
spicy addict you don't hate me next week
it's fine the balance is out take your
glory to start
and we have heartbeat it's a new member
for one year five dollars for chat
giving uh at Nintendo Taco shout out it
looks like oxen free 2 was announced at
Nintendo in the world in 2021 announced
uh to also come to PS4 and 5 in 2021
yeah
and we know Lord then we have Lord
Metroid member for one year two dollar
Super Chat I know it's the game all I
know is the game of the year releases on
May 12th Tick-Tock outside
there we got JD gamer remember for two
years five dollars from chat I don't
know where Staton thinks he's going
myself is going to be getting Netflix
soon so I'm stating this either a trojan
horse so he'll be coming home soon
okay 3D chess
could be could you go over there that
you go buy over there it'll be crazy but
like the bike I kind of like what
happened with bike now in a way like he
goes over there the the place is crazy I
doubt this is happening what but
three weeks ago or a couple months ago
it was originally coming to Xbox and
just when I was like nah I don't like
them anymore you're blocked that black
Savage shut it down shut it down shut it
down then we just go in there and hit
the order 66 button
but it's done Joe it's done nah
then we have either the guinna or the
Jenna I don't know which one it is tell
me which one it is two pound super chat
you think Xbox ever released a game pass
only game
unless they unless they make a decision
to not sell games on a car anymore
I doubt it they make money off of that
like there's no way they're just gonna
kiss that Revenue so the reason they
haven't got rid of Xbox Live they make
money off of it yeah
then we are splendiferous member for one
year five dollars which I remember Game
Pass as a waiting list so you know you
can't skip the line you gotta wait your
sack is not heavy enough to just get a
VIP room go hang with Jimmy no wow
hahaha
[Laughter]
there we get hold on and roll it back a
little bit
okay we have Spartan go 17 too probably
addict on that Godfather offer they
can't refuse
then we have Michael Askew Jr
did you all talk about how that octopath
two sales went Square found out that
move off Xbox didn't hit or not even I
said it bombed wait I have to pass yeah
apparently that's crazy I'm not 100 sure
on the cells it's like look like I don't
know if that game coming on Xbox would
have just magically made the sales be
better but it definitely would have been
better than it was it's just great I
heard that game Matty goes hard for it
it's a great game I just think you know
what it is too like I said I think it's
the shift in in the the PlayStation guys
thinking about like when you see in
Final Fantasy 16 you have to be a really
hardcore jrpg dude to be like I'ma sit
and play octopath too because it's just
one of those things it's a beautiful
game that that that's that beautiful 2D
3D stuff is gorgeous I'm surprised it's
sort of bottom jrpg yeah sometimes it
doesn't matter you know sometimes you
can have the hottest game in the world
if you know you release wrong dates to
come back whatever you don't have the
marketing it was like yeah it just
doesn't matter and then plus let's be
real like a lot of the mass people these
days look at Graphics like that and they
just like I am good on that like yeah
you see something like Final Fantasy 7
oh yeah for sure you've expanded that
franchise they're like I want Graphics
like that I'm
so in a way it might have hurt them to
just to eliminate to put it on to
eliminate Xbox but to it might have hurt
them to just not leave it as a as a
switch exclusive right because on the
switch you look at that like this game's
amazing
well or Swedish that surprisingly didn't
do well again PlayStation because they
they kind of diluted the the waters and
they they put it on Playstation as well
the numbers don't I think it would have
hit differently if it was just a switch
game don't put it over there you flop
that's not what I was getting actually
oh yeah so that's the guy with the
oxy-free too now kid
keeping the platform keep picking
yourself up
[Music]
then we got light x two dollar Super
Chat thank you appreciate that
then we have Nintendo on the otaku two
dollars for chat that Space Jam beat him
up was Xbox game pass exclusive
yeah not playing
it um I think we're good we're caught up
right King this last one is your tablet
when we set it up man yes sir all right
Joseph stay in the legend now going over
to Netflix games joins Netflix games and
he's gonna looks like he's gonna be
working on a brand new AAA game so he
made a statement on Twitter he said in
my work life there's nothing I love more
than collaborating with others to build
worlds filled with iconic characters
deep Mysteries and endless Adventures he
said goes on to say so today I'm
thrilled to announce that I've joined
Netflix games as creative director for a
brand new AAA multi-platform game and
original Ip let's go and then uh
Microsoft seemed to respond everything
seemed to be all good we're grateful for
Joseph's contributions to the Halo
franchise and Xbox as a whole and we
wish him all the best in his new
adventures so stay in over to Netflix
games King this is your topic where you
at
Okay so
this is a little bit uh conspiracy
theory and a little bit of
um hey I got sources too oh oh you're
NDA dude now and then they were wrong oh
I saw this in the background was like he
going to bungee that is true that is
true he said it and that's and I stood
on that see what happens when you listen
to somebody
you had just said from accounting that
could be factual it turns out to throw
egg in your face
shout out to him for going to Netflix
now if anybody can remember not too long
ago there was talks that Microsoft was
gonna buy Netflix yes it was in the
newspaper
I'm saying the headline what the hell is
going on here
all right so
Microsoft is the first people that um
says you know wish
standing well
wish you well
Mikey bar goes over here
Ferguson goes over here
deal is getting done
these dudes go over there prepare the
runway
[Music]
there's something over here with this
Netflix thing uh-huh
send our number one head over
so you you know it would be crazy kid
I'm gonna take it a step further they're
like look Mike if you secure that deal
we make sure you you having stuff over
there at blizzard continue listen when
that deal goes through we're gonna see
where Mike is we're gonna see where Rod
is we're gonna see exactly where they at
in the pecking order right yeah gold
watches giving out bonuses
he wasn't out of work long right no it
wasn't
quick quick quick did you snap your
finger he already had a job lined up and
Microsoft said I wish you well you
so you get over there I mean I'm just
saying
I don't know how y'all feel about him
going over there
but my thing my overarching thing my
third eye is open let's go that boy over
there preparing the runway for Microsoft
to buy Netflix because I'm gonna tell
you this I told people before
that Sony and Netflix is going to team
up
and that's going to turn Sony into the
largest video game uh conglomerate
overnight if they're able to use the
technology of they're watching you
watching god of war and you can be like
you can join in and play this game at
this moment right here and play from
there on right like you you in a part a
god award movie oh let's say you playing
the last of us watching The Last of Us
TV show and it's it's in Netflix and
let's you know just say yeah and then
you're able to click a button and take
over Ellie from this point on in the
actual game right and Sony owns that and
then they work with
um Netflix in that manner I thought
Netflix would be
the perfect home for Sony
standing going over there oh
that that deal shot the crap oh okay
okay so the vote the ball's in the
building they're setting up position I
think your chosen horse I I swear I do
because
um
it's just every time Microsoft somebody
leaves Microsoft and go someplace else
they wind up buying these people
that Kickstart ass office I thought you
know they got this um
they just invited him into a room he's
like Stayton I know
things didn't work with Halo except but
we got a door too do you want door two
what's in door two you put that like
he's like it's like it's the CIA it's
like this this package is gonna explode
the moment you open it
red pill a blue pill all right there
will be there will be a nice vacation
house for you in Florida
oh wow y'all really going on solve any
thoughts or the state the the Netflix I
will say this right I mean because it
hasn't been proven to not be the case it
know illicit business is funny man it's
not that I believe this wholeheartedly
but the fact that you know you had these
two guys go over the Activision Blizzard
and it and all of a sudden it's coming
back they're coming back into the fold
none of them has made a a kind of move
but like oh no you know I don't want to
be with Microsoft again I'm out of here
like yeah nobody said that right so you
just you never know because business if
anything funny man after the acquisition
was made
so listen I I again because it has not
been disproven in in other scenarios hey
you never know and you know I would put
Joe state in front of a like a boardroom
like hey you know
you guys over here they don't get cool
stuff we got together so I could see I
could see a scenario now come back down
to earth yes I could just see Joe just
sitting in a room
people was like whoa you know they're
just talking regular stuff and Joe's
like Microsoft wants them yeah let's see
continue and to me I mean again just
again apart from that scenario
you get Joe Staton because Joe Staton
has been known to be able to craft just
amazing Stories amazing worlds more
build all of that and you know I think
what I like about what Netflix is doing
is that they've seen the mistakes of
other players that tried to get into the
gaming space and they don't seem to be
making them as well you look at what
Google did with stadia they're not
leaning into the streaming part right
like the the kings that the stuff that
King mentioned is very cool right the
possibility of doing that but all of
that games are downloadable you go into
your your Netflix app
you could download that game to your
either to your phone or what you know
whatever
um whatever platform it's available on
that you're that you're playing the
Netflix on so that's one thing right so
they're not leaning into the cloud stuff
like cloud cloud another thing is that
they're not charging you more for it
right at least not overtly they may
raise their prices and other things but
they're not telling you they're raising
their prices because they're adding
games to it right right so
it's they're being smart about how they
implement this stuff and then little by
little they're they're increasing sort
of their their footprint in the space
all of a sudden you go from smaller
games games that can run on a phone that
have been on you know portable platforms
like the switch have been on you know PC
whatever the case may be
um to now
transitioning into we're going to make a
big AAA game we need somebody to come in
as a Lore Master and this game not only
is it going to be a AAA game but it's
going to be a multi-platform game so
we're not in this bag where it has to be
exclusive to our platform no way I
understand it for this to be as
successful as possible yo Brian they
like someone got to pay for this guy
somebody gotta pay for this game and all
these Netflix subscribers are going to
be doing it but at the same time like
hey you know let's let's sell it to
everyone else as well so to me it is
that thing of they're seeing the red the
tea leaves they're like okay we're gonna
do this we're gonna do it the right way
we're not going to step on the same
brakes that the stadiums have that act
that even the Amazon with the Lunas have
like they're not leaning into that at
some point that may be important right
um but I like what they're doing with
this and again stay in at the stating
with the ability now to come back into a
creative space right and even though you
know he he jumped at the chance to work
on Halo again and to sort of right that
ship and fix it right but the chance to
have once again come into a space where
it is his own yeah it is a brand new
thing for a creative individual creators
in general they're always looking for
the opportunity to have their new ideas
be able to grow and and become something
right I can see you getting tired of
working on the same stuff over and over
which is why like after he came in and
did what they were Halo and obviously
whatever happened behind the scenes
happened he's like I don't there's no
point in me continuing to be here I need
to find a different adventure and this
is it and he got a bag for it and I'm
assuming he has carte blondes in terms
of whatever it is he's trying to create
there so I'm I'm excited for it I'm
excited for it and again but I do say
that the that the uh the third eye
scenario could be a possible
you never know
salute to the legend you know stating uh
talked about this is one of the topics
on unlocked as well in reference look
his history is just just mind-boggling
like the like over 17 years this guy's
been holding it down and then you know
responsible for two of the literally the
series some of my favorite in gaming
which is Halo and Destiny and um you
know always going to respect that he got
off his couch to help uh Halo PC post
Craig you know what I'm saying and you
can come through and and in a consulted
role and give his expertise but to your
point so obviously you know it's one of
those things if you're a Creator and you
see a process like that and you're like
you know what maybe it's time you know
for me to to run my own thing he's been
doing you know so much and he's got more
than just game devs but he's got
narrative chops he's got writing chops
he wrote the story like he he his his
resume is just insane so not to mention
Cog like there's a difference between
being
there's a person that is in a line of
people and being the person at the talk
right and he's he's literally the amount
of money that they're gonna put into his
game because he's that first trip away
is probably insane the bag that Netflix
must have given this man had to be
insane that had to be an epic bag so
salute to him you know he's got a chance
to cash out and do things on his own you
know some kind of things and you're
starting to see this trend you know
whether it be like kind of Veteran you
know directors senior level guys either
like cash out on a studio tip after
they've been acquired or you know
they've been in a company long and then
they go kind of create their own student
you're starting to see that so that this
is one thing that I will say it's kind
of like a positive of post acquisition
in the sense that you're starting to see
people create their own Studios a dude
whatever so Netflix is trying to get in
the game we'll see you know the effect
of it
um I will say this though you know this
the other part that people are not
seeing is you know this cross media up
polarization of of games media movies
you know this is the wave you know what
you see now what cyberpunk Edge Runners
did for cyberpunk you know what I mean
you're seeing what Last of Us is doing
right now you know obviously people
don't like certain aspects with the HALO
Series but as far as the revenue as far
as the engagement it is Paramount's top
you know what I'm saying one of their
top shows so you're seeing that so don't
be surprised whatever he creates on a
huge level there will be some anime live
action whatever whatever you know
whatever whatever it relationship to
whatever this new IP is and yeah that I
think that's where gaming is going
they're starting to see you see the
Mario movie Sonic move like it it we're
here now this this cross-polarization of
of media so I think that's what's going
on in salute to him I don't know what's
going to happen with Acquisitions I'm
not mistaken or did they say that
already like that it was going to be
besides the whatever world is creating
for the game this is going to be
something more than that in terms of the
cross pollination did they say that I'm
not sure the official press release on
his thing yeah how to look that up yeah
so maybe they did I don't know I I I
didn't see him but I didn't read the
official press release which I should
probably should have done but uh yeah
that's all I was gonna say it's just
that um you you want especially Netflix
especially what they had Witcher they
had you know they got a lot going on in
Castlevania they you're going to see
something you know some kind of thing
and that again on those white boys
that's what that's where the money's at
so we'll see not to mention when they go
to make um
when they go to make deals with these
companies to produce their shows that
now since they own a gaming division
they're like yo we want gaming rights
too we ain't just doing show we want
both yeah well you could try to throw
you a script to someone else and he
could secure it back also on his resume
he helped remember before this TV show
stuff Halo was supposed to come out with
a movie with Peter Peter Jackson in him
back in the day
um Stayton was helping Peter Jackson
them write the script for the movie the
movie never came out back then I guess
me the games meaning wasn't ready at
that time but yeah he's got the chop so
I would not be surprised contractually
he's got all this laid out as far as his
incentives and all the stuff as far as
what he was done the only thing I care
about though is post Satan Halo infinite
narrative what happens you know shout
out to Pier Heights in the crew but
Paris has a good point he said
Hollywood's eye in the gaming industry
as yeah
this this is the new genre I agree with
Paris Mario was lit it was good it was
great movie it was a great movie and
again what's happened is you get a whole
new audience that are non-gamers
now yo what's my you know what's what's
Witcher you know what I'm saying what's
that let's go check last of us this is a
great story but oh I have a PlayStation
I play Call of Duty
exactly and then we saw I think about
MBD like Last of Us sales are crazy
right now so look there's that you know
that crossover right there we got to see
what's going on I do want to see what's
going on with Halo I do want to see
though narratively what's gonna happen
you know where they go with it we have
to wait after infinite that because you
know I still feel even though I thought
stating staying there was Consulting
them to give Halo infinite like infinite
like what the name was supposed to be
which is you're gonna be there to
continue to give us drops almost like an
expansion so I wonder how that changes
if at all with you know being that he
has departed I think that definitely
changed yeah and it may be like the next
Halo we have to wait but salute to him
he is a legend that's all I got but yeah
I think that he's got big things uh
planning on but uh that's all I got
we're gonna get super checks you want to
do the poll then I should remember this
time yeah go ahead and do it all right
no doubt um with the latest statements
by Xbox regarding High five Russia's
success which do you think is the
measurement Microsoft is utilizing for
Success a console and PC game sales B
Game Pass subscribers see user
engagement per title or D I don't care
all I know is these games need to be
fired those are the choices that please
knock the vote that I will put up and
remember is those seven eight hour show
I am going to remember to put these
polls back up it is on popping oh look I
need a new Tekken character which one
tell me the name tell me Nelson revealed
tell me what you're talking character
joined let me know what's going on
because I gotta go check that out in a
minute but that is all solved you want
to get the uh Super Chat sir yes sir
does it have too many more hold on and
no we got I think we're good nothing oh
no doubt we're caught up on it we make
sure let me make sure
you're good
nice little small four hours three hours
yeah
[Laughter]
sorry y'all sorry
if we could just
[Laughter]
very spicy Urban attic today where could
the fine people find you what you got
going on sir
you follow me on Twitter at Lord addict
ILP first off I want to say is I really
appreciate everyone for uh you know
supporting uh my personal YouTube
channel like people have been showing up
in like the the drones like it's it's
kind of insane like it's like one of
those things where like you start to see
some mild success yeah after doing this
for so many years and he was like yo
like okay you know it gives me
motivation to keep doing it yeah and
sometimes sometimes I'd be like nah I'm
good uh but you know I appreciate
everyone coming through I'm gonna put
the uh my channel in the in the chat
definitely go over there and uh sub to
sub to me man yeah I'm making daily
content just about at this point so go
over there and sub to that I appreciate
everyone coming through we add up to
like I think it's like 750 people uh if
by the end of the show you can get that
342 to 400. I'll schedule a uh a video
with me and the uh Lords uh rating all
the uh the the Xbox
Studios and we'll post it on the channel
channel uh but I appreciate it for
coming through uh keep in mind after the
show we're going to go live Straight
Into the Dead Island 2 review I hope you
guys enjoyed that it took me about I
would say 30 hours to beat that game
absolutely absolutely on that oh what
you call it the Jitter says after the
end game episode last week you guys now
going Disney plus with bite-sized
content this week
yeah
anyway Lord song we can find people
finds what you got going on sir you
can't find me going to work because
always but you know but I'm excited next
couple of weeks are exciting man we got
Jedi Survivor at the end of this
upcoming week and of course next week
after that we got red Falls oh yes yes
look for the Lords to be playing that
together and then doing that uh excited
exciting time so and like I said before
uh shout out to Baby bro happy birthday
everybody saying happy born day Lord
kite batsuit waking up now everybody
just waking up now like how long what if
they still go so yeah
and I got a couple of more Super chats
but I'll read that after everybody's
done no doubt little kid very quiet
today quiet King
well I was just trying to make sure that
we wasn't doing four hours
I'm not interjected today you're keeping
it
I want to yell out time so damn you
should have
your time
he's stupid
he's like I got nothing else to say no
no no it's Tuesday 5 p.m combat talk
with the King when Devin Haney and
lomachenko fights thank you nice I know
Dell and you already know salute
everybody in the room again thank you
all for 300 man that was super dope the
love was beyond Phil I watched it back a
few times and it was really cool little
10K to the eye of certain parts I was
like yo that was the salute to the realm
for pulling up and hitting the like
button all that good stuff you want to
get these last Super chats then we get
about it yes sir we got Lord Metroid two
dollars Super Chat my inviting stick is
ready for Street Fighter six let's go
pause yes
my Saturn my Saturn pad is ready as well
I think at the end of this week
everybody else gets the demo I'm not
sure but I think it's at the end of this
week yeah I think so I think so it comes
to all the platforms yeah other
platforms I don't know if I think it's a
week
there you go there you go
three five to six Nintendo Taco two
dollars for the chat Tekken 8 gots that
got stepping up gotta step it up after
everything Street Fighter 6 is doing yes
yes
it looks fire I think it both coexist to
be dope so I'm trying to make one all
dominating together and stop that tuck
it ain't like fire sir yeah they're two
different games uh rrd to 2.20 Super
Chat R.I.P Shakespeare yes sir all right
yeah send some love to Randolph 119. yes
sir then we got Simon McKenzie five
dollar Super Chat drop it a little bit
more just for the show the last a little
bit longer all right I love you all guys
keep up with the excellent content oh
much love he loves you more King
appreciates all of that
we know next week's three-hour topic APK
and the CMA I will say if that once that
deal gets fire lives you already know
the whole Community to go pull up and
they want to hear kids
can can we support my man pgk blam on
his 300th episode absolutely yes
absolutely let's go with what's up he
hit it all right I think is it next week
or next week I think it's next week but
I hope but hold on because I think I'm
supposed to come through I don't believe
this week shout out to blame though
shout out to blame anyway yeah Shop cast
yes do your thing we all good we're good
we're caught up all right everybody
enjoy your weekend some more fun stuff
plan you got stuff cooking and uh that's
all I got but everybody that Island too
guys oh yeah hit the like button
immediately
[Music]
thank you